and okay you're very professional you
know people are like how do you live and
things like that they're taking money
from the Russians and of course the
answer's no but I I do this for a living
like I speak I don't have a youtube
channel that where it's you know I'm Joe
Rogan but I give speeches at
universities and things like that I do a
lot of interviews and so we're recording
now and set up ooh is it possible that
you could do a YouTube channel
would that work yeah like I I mean if
you introduced me so like I get
followers yeah we could do that too I'm
all-in with that that could absolutely
happen do you want to do that is it
something you want to do no I mean this
is a big question so I I came on because
I just written a book called permanent
record which is the the story of my life
because that's what publishers make you
do and when you're writing your first
book but it's more than that because I
didn't just want to talk about me it's
actually about the changing of
Technology and the changing of
government in this sort of post 9/11 era
which you know our generation just sort
of happened to be growing up during and
I was at the CIA and the NSA and all
this stuff but the day that the book
came out the government hit me with a
lawsuit and they hit the publisher of
the books with a with a lawsuit because
they don't want to see books like this
get written they especially don't want
to see books like this get read and so
the big thing was you know we didn't
know where this was going we didn't know
what was gonna happen and my publisher
of course wanted me very badly to let
people know this book existed in case
the government leaned hard and harder
harder we didn't know where where that's
going
I mean the government is still pursuing
that case quite strongly they're more
focused on though the financial
censorship side of it basically taking
any money that I made from it kind of is
a warning to the others and getting a
legal judgment against the publishers
saying you know you can't pay this guy
that kind of thing more so than taking
the book off the shelves but that's not
because they're okay with the book being
on the shelves it's because thankfully
we've got the first of
and so they can't and that's a very rare
and good thing but anyway in the context
of that they were like well what about
Joe Rogan and you know I I had heard
about you at this point but you know the
only thing that I had really seen that I
really understood had familiarity with
was like you talking to Bernie Sanders
which by the way I very much appreciated
hearing them because a lot of people
don't give the guy time to talk yeah to
hear him in those sound bites you don't
really get an understanding of who he
actually is right and this is the other
thing like they're like well you know
you can go on all these you know major
Network shows and I I did a couple of
them I did like a morning show I did
Brian Williams but broadly the media the
the the sort of more corporatized media
as we might say is exactly what you just
described right they they want you to be
able to answer in like 8 15 seconds or
less and when we're talking about big
massive shifts in society we're talking
about power we're talking about
technology and how it controls and
influences us in the future
you you can't have a meaningful
conversation with them those constraints
and so it said these guys all want to
say repeat these long discredited sort
of criticisms and you know I'm sure
you'll you'll you'll ask the same thing
and that's ok they're there for
questions but it's like we can't have
the conversation if we can't have this
space to think right breathe and have
this sort of discussion so anyway they
mentioned you
and I was like Joe Rogan Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan where do I know this name from
before Bernie Sanders and I look back
through my Twitter mentions and the
funny thing is your fans have been
harassing me to death for like the last
year's wonderful people wonderful people
but like go on Joe Rogan go on Joe Rogan
and I remember like after I had just
made a Twitter account Neil deGrasse
Tyson actually I helped me get on
Twitter gave me that little initial
boost and they said Joe Rogan and so I
they like linked you and you know I I
mouse over your name cuz I use a desktop
for this because security reasons and it
pops up and I get your avatar man and
like I have to say your logo it's the
worst thing in the world for people who
are like trying to be like politically
serious and you know they're worried
about the National Security Adviser
condemning because like this bald guy
with this maniacal grin and like the
third eye on his forehead and I'm like
oh man that's show but it's actually
like you watch you know wouldn't when
you watch what you do is it's great
stuff man it's great but that first
impression like I this almost didn't
happen but everybody who has talked to
you you know everybody who watches your
show I think they get a very different
impression and then how you're paying it
and for me it's a wonderful thing
because nobody understands that better
than I do right like the government ran
a smear campaign against me endlessly
for six months when I came forward in
June of 2013 I know we got way off topic
here oh I'll get back to it fine
there's no such thing as off topic we
could do okay talk about whatever great
great okay so for those people first off
who have no idea who the hell I am
I'm the guy who was behind the
revelations of global mass surveillance
in 2013 I worked for the CIA I worked
for the NSA as a contractor at the NS a
staff officer the CIA I was undercover
working at embassies but and I talked
about the difference between this and a
book and contractor and government
official and how it's all sort of lost
its meaning but I saw something wrong
and I saw basically the government was
violating the law and what I believe to
be the Constitution of the United States
and more broadly human rights for
everyone in the United States and around
the world there were domestic
surveillance programs there were mass
surveillance programs that worked
internationally basically everything
that they could monitor led they were
monitoring and this is actually like
people go war isn't that obvious isn't
that what they're supposed to do and
this is weird but the answer actually is
no under the framework of our
Constitution the government is only
supposed to be monitoring people that it
has a individualized particularized
suspicion of wrongdoing for right this
is we think about this in the investing
if means right like all those TV shows
where they're like go and get a warrant
the reason they have to do that like we
fought a revolution over this you know a
couple hundred years back is the idea
that when we had you know Kings when we
had governments of absolute power they
could simply go in your home and go you
know is this guy pot smoker get his
diary you know whatever it is and just
like if you find evidence of a crime you
March them off to prison and it's all
good you found evidence they're criminal
or you didn't find evidence well no harm
no foul
you're just doing what government does
we were trying to build a better system
where when yes the government has
extraordinary capabilities but it only
uses them whether they're necessary
right where they're proportionate to the
threat that is presented by this person
you know like we shouldn't be afraid of
the person who's got like a baggie of
weed in their dresser or something like
that that is not a threat to national
security that's not a threat to public
safety but what happened in the wake of
9/11 was a whole bunch of government
officials got together behind closed
doors and this was actually led
interestingly enough by the Vice
President of the United States Cheney
everybody remembers that name or
hopefully I can look that name up Dick
Cheney and his personal attorney sort of
the the Giuliani of Dick Cheney a guy
named David Addington
and this lawyer David Addington wrote a
secret legal interpretation but no one
else was allowed to see it was kept in
the vice president's safe at the White
House they weren't giving this even when
they told people and it was just a
couple people in Congress Nancy Pelosi
was one of them on a couple of these
other folks when they talked to the
heads of the agency the NSA and the CIA
and the FBI and all this stuff they told
them the White House in the office of
legal counsel and you know this this the
president's attorneys all of these guys
had decided this would be legal to do
but we can't tell you why we can't show
you the legal authorization where you
just got to take our word for it
and so they
did this and this became a mass
surveillance program called stellar wind
which they said was supposed to monitor
the phone calls in Internet
communications emails and things like
that of everybody in the United States
and around the world who they could get
access to for links al Qaeda because if
you remember in the wake of the
September 11th attacks they were singing
we thought there could be sleeper cells
about Qaeda that we've just you know
peppered all throughout the country they
were gonna spring up at any moment of
course like weapons of mass destruction
it just didn't exist it was all the
power grab
but on that basis they started doing
this in secret and it was completely
unconstitutional was completely illegal
even under the very loose requirements
of the Patriot Act but they did it for
so long that they got comfortable with
it and they thought this is it you know
this is a really powerful capability
what have we started using this for
stuff that was other than terrorism
because it wasn't finding any terrorists
because there weren't any terrorists in
this context that we're looking for them
and the ones who we're there were
terrorists the program wasn't affected
because these were guys in Pakistan that
weren't using you know email and phone
calls they were getting on you know
moped with their cousin who was a
courier who was bringing a letter to his
guy you know who runs the the food stand
or whatever but bit by bit over time
this grew and grew and grew and there
were scandals and if you want to drill
down in these later all going to him but
what happened was step by step by step
our constitutional rights were changed
and we weren't allowed to know it we
were never granted a vote on it and even
the many members of Congress right 535
in the United States they were
prohibited from knowing this and instead
they told only a few select people yeah
in the original case there were only
eight members of Congress called the
gang of eight who knew about this then
there were the people on the
intelligence committees both in the
Senate in the house who were told about
this but they were only told partially
about it they weren't told the full
scope of it and now that they had been
told about it because they had security
clearances and
like that they weren't allowed to tell
anybody else even if they objected to it
and we had one Senator Ron Wyden I mean
another one I believe Tom Udall was
named of him who did object to this and
who wanted something to happen but
because they couldn't tell anybody that
was happening they were sort of doing
these weird lassie barks to the press
where they were like we have grave
concerns about the way these programs
are being carried out but nobody knew
what they were talking about and so
journalists were like you know they've
got concerns what is that Lassie what
are you trying to say timmy's them well
but they were getting it wrong they
couldn't tell what was happening so what
had happened was that we the American
people had sort of lost our seat at the
table of government we were no longer
partner to government we had simply
become subject to government and I think
everybody who's in the world today who
is aware of what's going on whether it's
under this administration last
administration the one before that right
they have seen a constant kind of shift
where we have we the public have less
say and less influence over the policy
of government with each passing year
there's kind of a new class that's being
created a government class and then the
public civil class that are held to
different standards of behavior and when
we start talking about leaking and
whistleblowing this becomes even more
clear and so what I did was I wanted to
clarify that kind of lassie bark right I
just wanted everybody to know what was
going on I didn't want to say the
government can't do this I didn't want
to say this is how you guys have to live
because that's not for me to say now but
I do believe that everybody in the
United States and more broadly people in
the world who are having their rights
violated by a government should have at
least an understanding of how that is
happening what the authorities sort of
the policies and programs that are
enabling that or so that they can
protest them so that they can cast a
vote about them so that they can't say
you know what you guys say this is okay
but I disagreed that this is not okay I
object and I want things to change and
so I gathered evidence of what I believe
to be a criminal or unconstitutional
activity on the part of government and I
gave this to journalists right
now I gave this to journalists under a
very strict condition here which was
that they publish no story in this
archive of information simply because it
was interesting right no clickbait not
anything just because they thought it
would make news that we get them awards
they would only publish stories that
they were willing to make an
institutional judgment and stand behind
and this was three different newspapers
that it was in the public interest to
know and so then beyond that there was
additional is because if you could see
sort of what I was doing here what had
happened what had led us into this
pitfall was that the system of checks
and balances that's supposed to
self-regulate our government had failed
the courts had abdicated their role in
policing the executive in the Congress
because terrorism was such a hot
argument at the time they were worried
about being criticized and blamed if
something went wrong an attack did go
through and they didn't have access to
the information that the programs were
ineffective so they were just taking the
government's word for it they didn't
want to wait in Congress most of them
didn't even know right and the ones who
did know it was the same thing they were
getting their pockets stuffed with money
by the defense contractors that were
getting rich for building these systems
that were violating the rights of each
of us so they benefited by just saying
nothing and then the executive
themselves whether we're talking about
Bush right whether we're talking about
Obama or whether we're talking about
Trump now all these guys were okay with
a constantly growing surveillance state
because they're the ones whose hands
were on the lever at the time they got
to aim it they got to use it if you had
a little search box in front of you they
would give you the email history and you
know of everybody in the United States
anybody you want if you could pull up
their text messages anybody you want if
you could see anything they've ever
typed into that Google search box right
Joe what is the worst thing you've ever
typed into that search box that lasts
forever
right and they have a record of that
they can get that from Google and so
this was this was the whole thing how do
we correct for that so when you have
somebody
who wants to inform the public of
something and we'll get into the proper
channels arguments later but you can't
go through the institution to get these
corrected because the institution knows
it's wrong and is doing it anyway right
that's the whole origin of the program
is they want to do something that
they're not allowed to do what do you do
right and so I didn't want to say I'm
the president of Secrets I didn't want
to just put this stuff on the internet
and I could have on the technologist
right I worked with the journalists and
then that to create an adversarial step
right someone who would argue against
what I believed and hopefully what the
journalists believe once they consulted
the documents and basically
authenticated them can we get the
government to play that role right and
so before the journalists published any
story this is a controversial thing
people still criticize me for this
actually they say I was too
accommodating government think they
could be right is that the journalist
would go to the government and give them
warning say we're about to run this
story about this secret program that
says you did X Y & Z bad thing one is
that right and the government always go
over no comment right - is this gonna
cause harm is anybody gonna get hurt is
this program effective is there
something we don't understand right as
if something Snowden doesn't understand
it is this guy just not get it right are
these documents fake whatever you want
say we shouldn't run this story in every
case I'm aware of that process was
followed and that's why right it was
because there's a lot of people out
there who don't like me who criticize me
who go this was unsafe this caused harm
to people or whatever we're in 2019
now I came forward and these stories
weren't the Pulitzer Prize for public
service journalism starting way back in
June of 2013 we've had six years to show
bodies we've had six years to show harm
and you know as well as I do the
government's happy to leak things when
it's in in their interest nobody has
been hurt as a result of these
disclosures because everyone who was
involved in them was so careful we
wanted to maximize
the public benefit while mitigating the
potential risks and I think we did a
pretty good job but just to get back to
the the main thing and the original
thing that got us off on that trail
when I came forward in June of 2013 and
I gave one interview to the people who
were in the room with the documents
Laura Poitras Glenn Greenwald you and
McCaskill and I said who I was I said
why I was doing this I said what this
was about why it matters and that we
were constructing a system of turnkey
tyranny and even if you trust that to
Obama you never know whose hand is gonna
be on that key next and all I have to do
is turn it and there's nothing we can do
to stop it the only thing that's
restraining these programs really is is
policy more so than the law and the
President and anytime can sign a napkin
and those policies change well after
that I went six months without giving
any interviews because I didn't want
people to talk about me and I wanted
them to talk about what actually
mattered and the government of course
was trying very hard to change the
conversation as they always do to be
about who is this guy what have they
done right what's wrong with them what
are their problems who is this this
loony guy so they can controversial eyes
the source of a story rather than having
to confront that the story itself and
that's why I said it's I I really kind
of appreciate your your take on the
media and everything like that because
when you don't tell your story you know
other people will tell it for you
they'll say so many things about you and
they'll have these misimpressions like I
did because if something is stupid as
the avatar that you were using on
Twitter right well I think it's a
certain kind of show with a certain kind
of guy and it's this crazy stuff but
when I actually listen to you when I
actually look at the facts right and
when I hear you just speak I go actually
this is a thoughtful guy actually this
is somebody who does care who does want
to look at these things deeply and
appearances and our first impressions
can be very misleading I work hard on
that I try to mislead people it's good
works to my advantage do a good job man
thank you
I want to bring it back to when you
first started with the NSA you started
as a contractor right what was your
initial impression and when did you know
that things were really squirrely with
the programs that sort of thing so I'm
not saying this to put put you on the
spot I know you've been a busy guy I
don't know you hadn't done I think shows
recently you come back from break right
but have you read the book because it'll
just help me your boyfriend if you
haven't got a chance
you know no I have not read your book or
got a copy of it okay well I will send
you a signed copy brother beautiful I
don't hope you'll read it and I hope you
enjoy it but alright so I had a really
weird history in the intelligence
community I grew up in a federal family
in the shadow of Fort Meade right all
these little suburban communities in
Maryland where basically the entire
industry of the state is the federal
government of all these different
agencies and then all the subcontractors
all the defense industries that serve
that government and really are kind of
our war making a machine are our system
of control for the country and the world
broadly all that stuff spreads and you
know a couple hundred mile radius out of
DC my mother worked for the district
courts rather than federal courts and
it's kind of funny because she still
works there and those are the courts
that are trying to throw me in jail for
the rest of my life now my father worked
for the Coast Guard retired after 30
years my grandfather was an admiral and
then he worked for the FBI as far back
as it goes my my family my whole line of
family even generations back was working
for the government um so it was pretty
ordinary pretty expected for me to go
into the same kind of work now I started
and I wasn't super successful in school
because it I felt and you know this is
the most arrogant thing in the world
than anybody says
that I had more to learn from computers
than I did from you know biology class
and so I spent more and more time
focusing on technology then I got mono
and I dropped out of high school and now
it's like alright how do I make this up
I drop out of high school but I'm
actually going to Community College
right they called it concurrent
enrollment where I'm not taking any
classes at high school I'm going to
Community College instead and I'm not
doing that great they're either like
it's fine
you know I'm enjoying it but you know
school is school I I want I can't wait
to be grown you're aboard um and I think
a lot of people have felt that but I ran
into somebody at the Community College
who ran their own home-based business
doing web design and they could see I
was kind of technical and they went hey
do you want to work for me and I was
like the woman that sounds great and so
I started doing web design really really
early on this is like gosh I don't know
probably a 1998 vintage during the big
boom and then the collapse that followed
and the funny thing is she worked she
was married to an NSA analyst a linguist
right and so she lived on Fort Meade and
she ran her business out of their home
on Fort Meade that's right up the street
from the NSA so before I'm even working
there I'm driving past this building all
of the time and trying to figure out you
know what the next step is gonna be and
I enjoy this it's it's a good thing for
me and it like it works well and I start
getting trained and certified all these
little industry stamps you've got to get
as a technologist to say oh you know
this program or whatever and just start
climbing the ladder but then 9/11
happens and I'm on Fort Meade when 9/11
happens I'm just going into work and I
tell this in the book in some detail and
I think it's very much worth reading
four people don't know this because this
forgotten history but how old were you
at this money uh uh OSH I was I was born
at 83 so I was probably 18 years old and
yeah yeah I just turned 18 a couple
months before and what people forget is
who knew what was going on before
anybody else Wow on September 11th the
intelligence community right and what
did they do right did they give out a
public warning did they tell you guys to
evacuate did they say do this adder
doesn't know no not for everybody not
for a long time but at the NSA then
director Michael Hayden he was a general
he later became a director of the CIA
ordered the entire campus evacuated of
thousands tens of thousands of people
actually just said go home right
the CIA did the same thing they were
running on skeleton crews at the moment
the country needed them more than they
ever had right and I get a call well not
hear a call that's from my boss's wife
her husband to her he's calling from the
NSA he's saying hey you know I think
edge leave for the day because I'm the
only employee of this business besides
her because I think they're gonna close
the base down and I'm like this is crazy
they've never closed us down we don't
know what's happening then we start
checking the news which is through
websites right because we're we're doing
all this stuff and suddenly it's the big
story everywhere and you know nobody
understands how big it is yet most of us
are like oh it's gonna mess with our
workday oh it's gonna mess with our
commute but when I'm leaving I hear car
horns all over the base it's the
craziest thing because this is a
military base right it's right outside
the NSA and I entered just this absolute
state of pandemonium as I go past k9
road which is the road that travels
right and Pat it
in front of the NSA's headquarters and
it's just a parking lot as far as you
can see they have military police out
under the stoplights directing traffic
because this is this mass evacuation and
I still have no idea what's happening
like the the story is still developing
but I will never forget that image why
did these people have so much power and
so much money and so much authority that
if at the moments we need them the most
there are the first ones in the country
that are leaving their buildings and you
know later on they said and this is uh
covered in a book I believe I think it's
James Bamford who interviewed that
director of NSA who gave that order
about what was happening he was going
well you know he called his wife and he
was asking where their kids were and
everything like that and then after that
he wanted to think about well where
could these other planes that they knew
were in the air that it hadn't struck
yet where could they be headed and this
sort of shows how self centric the
intelligence community is this is the DC
metro area right they get hit the white
house they get hit Congress they get hit
the Supreme Court right I think oh
they're gonna fly their planes into the
CIA headquarters oh they're gonna fly
their planes into the NSA headquarters
and of course it was never realistic
that these would be the targets but on
that basis they were like oh let's get
our bacon out of the pan but why say
this I'm sorry but just in the interest
of what wasn't it possible that they
could have attacked those places I mean
they attacked the Pentagon they you know
they knew that there was attacked look
it's it's absolutely possible they could
have attacked your Denny's right you
know but it's a question of risk
assessment if you have planes in the air
if you believe there's an ongoing
terrorist attack that's happening in the
United States
right now and if you have built
history's greatest surveillance agencies
right that the most powerful
intelligence forces in the history of
the species you are gonna take those off
the board or at least the majority of
their personnel off the board then in a
chance that you have no sort of grounds
for substantiating that they could be
targeting you to begin with simply
because they could well somebody else
will get hit with those as you say it's
gonna be the Pentagon right it's gonna
be the World Trade Center it's gonna be
someone somewhere and the more minutes
you're in front of that desk the higher
the chances even if it's a very small
chance even if it's somebody who doesn't
work on terrorism right maybe if it's
somebody who normally works finance in
North Korea right but they go look this
is an emergency everybody understands
you don't need to explain this you just
go stop what you're doing look at
financial transactions related to who
purchased these plane tickets and do
this you just go full spectrum and go
anything you can do right now if the
building gets hit we get hit that's what
we signed up for nobody wants that right
that that's not the desired outcome but
if they had asked the staff to do then
they all would have agreed that's what
these people signed up to do and yet the
director goes no you know we're just
just know like we're not gonna take that
writ and this is I think it says so much
about the bureaucratic character of how
government works right the people who
rise to the top of these governments
it's about risk management for them
right it's about never being criticized
for something and this is look if we
want to get really controversial this is
something that'll that'll haunt me
because people will bring it up again
and again and again people ask about you
know people still criticize me in the
book you know I talk about aliens and
chemtrails and things like that effect
there there's no evidence for that I
went looking on the network right and
III know Joey
I know you want there to be aliens a
doob I know Neil deGrasse Tyson badly
once there to be aliens and there
probably are right but the idea that
that we're hiding them if we are hiding
them I had ridiculous access to the
networks at the NSA the CIA the military
all these groups I couldn't find
anything right so if it's hidden and it
could be hidden it's hidden really damn
well even for people who are on the
inside but the main thing is conspiracy
theories right everybody wants to
believe in conspiracy theories because
it helps life make sense it helps us
believe that somebody has control in
control right that somebody is calling
the shots that these things all happen
for a reason to stand the other there
are real conspiracies but they're not
typically you know they've got tens of
thousands of people working on them
unless you're talking about the
existence of the intelligence community
itself which is basically constructed on
the idea that you can get I I think
there's a four million or 1.4 million
people in the United States who hold
security clearances and you can get all
of these people to not talk ever the
journalists in this that or the other
but when you look back at the 9/11
report and when you look back at the
history of what actually happened what
we can prove right not what we can
speculate on but what are at least two
commonly agreed facts not it's very
clear to me as someone who worked in the
intelligence community not during this
period of course I was too young but
very shortly thereafter that these
attacks could have been prevented and in
fact the government says this too but
the government goes the the reason that
they these attacks happen the reason
that they weren't prevented is what they
call stovepiping right there was there
was not enough sharing they needed to
break down the walls and the
restrictions that were chaining these
poor Patriots at the NSA and the CIA and
the FBI from all working on the same
team and to some extent they're they're
correct on this right there there were
limits on
Way agencies were supposed to play ball
with each other but I worked there and I
know how much of this is [ __ ] and
how much as this is not those are
procedural and policy limits in some
cases legal limits on what can be shared
without following process without doing
this that or the other without basically
asking for permission without getting a
sign-off or anything like that
if the FBI wanted to send absolutely
everything they had to the CIA they
could have done so if the CIA wanted to
send everything they had to the FBI they
could have done so they didn't and
people died as a result now government
goes bureaucratic procedural ISM was
responsible and it's because we had too
many restrictions on the intelligence
community and this is what led to the
world post 9/11 where all of our rights
sort of evaporated was they went well
restrictions on what these agencies can
do are costing lives therefore naturally
we just have to unchain these guys and
everything will be better right and if
you remember that post 9/11 moment you
can understand how that actually could
come off as persuasive how that might be
a kind of thing to go you go all right
well will that make sense because
everybody was terrified right there were
people quite quickly who got their heads
back on their shoulders the right way
there were some of them who never lost
their heads at all and who protested the
Iraq war
at the same time lion-o himself was
signing up to go fight it volunteering
for the army and we're getting into that
a minute but everything that has
followed in the decades past came from
the fact that in a moment of fear we
lost our heads and we abandoned all the
traditional constitutional restraints
that we put on these agencies and we
abandon all of the traditional political
restraints and just social constraints
ideological systems of belief about the
limitations that the secret police
should have in a free and open society
and we went look you know terrorists we
created shows like 24 and Jack Bauer
where he's like threatening knife
people's eyeballs out if they won't tell
him this that
the other and we entered this era of
increasingly unlimited government as a
result and now in hindsight we go we
should have been surprised but at the
time everyone everyone panicked trying
but if you go back to you did that help
and we know the answer now is in fact no
it did not
it made things worse I don't think any
historian is gonna look at the Bush
administration and go this improved the
position of the United States in the
world but if you go back you don't wind
back the tape to that pre 9/11 moment
lying back the tape to those silos and
those walls that they said needed to
come down because that was restraining
government instead of the rules that
said we can't share these things but
there's got to be a basis there's got to
be a justification you've got to go why
are we trading people's information like
baseball cards and all of this stuff
it's super easy as an intelligence
officer to justify sharing information
about a suspected terrorist who you
think is planning to kill people or is
even just in a country they shouldn't be
or a place they shouldn't be or doing
something you don't think they should be
with another agency because no one's
gonna question that a judge isn't gonna
question that any judge in the world
will stamp that warrant without even
thinking about it and go to bed that
night you know without a care in the
world because you're not spying on a
journalist you know spying on a human
rights defender right this is not an
edge case now this is someone that you
believe to be associated with al-qaeda
or whatever now this is all a lot of
preamble to say that essential fact
government agrees everyone agrees the
attacks probably could have been
prevented if information had been shared
so why wasn't the information shared
government says information wasn't
shared because of these restrictions and
it's half true because every important
lie has has some criminal truth to it
and and there were these barriers but
the reality is why were those barriers
respected in the case of a major
terrorist plot why wasn't the CIA
sharing information with the FBI why
wasn't the FBI sharing information with
the NSA why was the Anastacia sharing
information with the CIA in the case of
Mary major terrorists
and if you've worked in government if
you've worked in the intelligence
community if you worked in any large
institution you know if you work at a
company that sells batteries you know
that every office is fighting the other
office for budget for cloud for
promotions and this is the sad reality
of what actually happened every one of
those agencies wanted to be the guy who
busted the plot they wanted to be the
one who got credit for it and they
didn't realize how serious it was until
it was too late because they were
competing with each other rather than
cooperating that's exactly what I was
gonna ask you if that was the issue the
competition between these agencies
because they are very proud of the CIA
accomplishing something with the FBI
accomplishing something and they they
want to be the one to take credit for
that yeah and I mean I think it's
important like in their defense because
nobody else here is gonna provide a
defense for them is that that's actually
darkly human again this happens in every
industry this happens in every sort of
big corporate thing because you want to
get promoted and you know everybody's
putting in their like achievements at
the end of the year for what they did if
you're the guy who does that you're
going straight to the top but their
solutions status was the the so we we
have a weird delay here for folks that
are listening claim their solution
instead of having someone be responsible
for bridging the gap and providing that
information to each individual agency
their solution was mass surveillance
well no they're they're different things
this is 9/11 is what woke these guys up
ROM basically and they went well we
screwed up and Americans died as a
result we really don't want to take the
hit on that and to be honest the
government had no interest in putting
the hit on them to be honest the public
had no interest in putting the hit on
them at the time because everybody
understood terrorism is a real thing
there are bad people in the world and
that's true right that will always be
true there's always going to be
criminals there's always going to be
terrorists whether they're at your
Church whether they're across the ocean
there are people out there who are angry
they're disenfranchised they're violent
and they just want to harm something
they want to change something even in a
negative way because that's what they
feel is all they have left which these
are criminals right these are people
that we don't need to pity but if we
ever want to stop it we do need to
understand it and where those things
come from where there's there's drives
come from in the first place but
basically everybody went alright how do
we stop this because nobody wants to
feel unsafe nobody wants to feel like
the building's gonna come down then the
next time you go in it and so everybody
just went I don't care who does it stop
it and they said this to Dick Cheney
which is a historic mistake but cuz date
Dick Cheney knows how government works
he was the person in that White House
who was best placed to know all the
levers of government all the interagency
cooperation where we were strong where
were weak what we could do what we were
not allowed to do and what he did was he
took that little dial on what we're not
allowed to do and he changed it all the
way until it broke and snapped off and
then there was nothing that we couldn't
do anymore and you were in there why
this was happening this was this no I
was I was not again this is 2001 I was I
was 18 years old I was working on the
base I had drove past the building but
that was it this is all hindsight this
is biography this is documented history
but this is not you know the Gospel of
Edward Snowden I I don't know this right
this is public record this is Ken what
we all know what we have though the the
reason that I bring this up is this is a
teachable moment because there's so many
people right now in the Trump
administration who go look this guy has
too much power he's abusing it against
immigrants he's abusing it against
domestic ponents he's doing whatever
he's trying to hurt political rivals in
the next election all of this stuff and
you know we can get into this stuff
later if you want in detail but the
bottom line is they're going this is a
guy
who's in the White House is throwing
elbows right he doesn't really care he
wants to hurt people as long as he can
convince the Americans that those are
the bad guys right that's the enemy
doesn't matter if they're far away it
doesn't matter if they're close at home
whoever he's against he's gonna harm and
the dark thing is this is actually why
he was elected in moments of fear where
the world starts falling apart and this
happens in a thornton country after
country this is why you have Vladimir
Putin in Russia who's been there for 20
years right president for basically 20
years think about that you know he sort
of skipped in the middle there because
he had to dodge the fact that presidents
can only serve so many consecutive terms
so he dropped down a prime minister and
then came back as president but think
about that how do you get that kind of
political longevity and it's because if
you know anything about Russian history
which you know I even I don't know that
much about it the 90s after the collapse
of the Soviet Union we're an
extraordinarily dark time if you look at
Russian cinema all they had or gangster
movies right all they had were the
disintegration of society how things are
dark and broken no one trusts each other
pensions were no longer being paid
Social Security's not there anymore like
there's nothing to buy there's nothing
to do there's no job no one had a future
and so they went if there's somebody who
can lead us out of this if there's
somebody who will fix this who will find
us an enemy and defeat that enemy to
restore prosperity we'll put them in
office we see it happen in Turkey with
Iran right we've seen it happen
successively with bad governments even
in Western democracies we see it
happening sadly in places like Poland
and Hungary
you can even argue it's happening in the
United Kingdom right and now there are a
lot of people arguing that sisk exactly
what we're seeing with Donald Trump's
White House in the United States and
this is the lesson that we didn't learn
from 2001 is when we become fearful we
become vulnerable right to anyone who
promises they will make things better
even if they have no ability to make
things better even if they will actively
things worse even if they will make
things better for themselves and their
buddies by taking from you but if they
tell you that they'll make things better
and you believe them
in a moment of fear that typically leads
to unfortunate outcomes so sorry let me
let me turn this back over to you
because we got way off track there no
that's all right I want to bring it back
to the initial question so you're
working for the NSA when do you realize
there's a huge issue and when do you
feel this responsibility to let the
American people know about this issue
like when when do you contact these
journalists and what was the thought
process regarding this like what what
steps did you go through once you
realize that this was in violation of
the Constitution and that even with the
laws of the Patriot Act in the Patriot
Act two things had changed so radically
that you knew this was wrong and you had
to do something about it you felt a
responsibility to speak out okay
so since we gave so much historical
preamble let me just give the the Cliff
Notes version okay to get us up to that
so after September 11th I'm a little bit
lost I'm doing my technical stuff but it
doesn't really feel like it matters
anymore like I'm making more money I'm
becoming more accomplished but the
world's on fire right if you remember
there was a crazy mood of patriotism in
the country
because we were all trying to come
together get through it you remember
like people were sticking Dixie Cups on
the top of every chain-link fence on
every overpass that was like stand
together you know never forget mm-hmm
united we stand flags on every car
exactly and you know I was a young young
guy who is not especially political
right and I come from a military
background federal family all that stuff
and so that means I'm very vulnerable to
this kind of stuff I see it on the news
and Bush and all his sort of cronies are
going look it's al Qaeda it's terrorism
terrorist organization they have all
these international connections
there's Iraq you know dictators weapons
of mass destruction they're holding the
world at ransom you got Colin Powell at
the UN dangling little vials of like
fake anthrax
and so I felt an obligation to do my
part and so I've volunteered to join the
army yeah you you probably can't tell
from from looking at me but I'm not
gonna be at the top of the MMA circuit
anytime soon so it didn't work out I
joined a special program that was called
the 18 X ray program where they take you
in off the street and they actually give
you a shot at becoming a Special Forces
soldier so you train harder and special
platoons you go further and I ended up
breaking my legs basically so they put
me out of your legs discharged
yeah it was basically what it was when
they were shin splints that I was too
dumb to get off of right so I kept
marching under wait I'm a pretty light
guy to begin with I had a 24 inch waist
when I when I joined the army girls are
jealous my way yeah I think I weighed
like a hundred and twenty-eight pounds
III got I was in great shape you know in
boot camp because I came up really quick
because it was a you know all I could do
was gain but it was it was just too much
on my frame because I wasn't that that
active and so when you keep running on a
stress injury right and you're running
under weight with like rucksacks and
things like that you're running in like
boots and then you're doing exercises
and the Army's like a whole chapter in
the book you you got your battle buddy
right because they never allow you to be
alone I was gonna have somebody watching
you they thought it was funny to put me
the smallest guy in the platoon that the
drill sergeants did with the biggest
dude in the platoon it was like an
amateur bodybuilders like you know 230
260 something like that he's a big
fellow and so you know he would uh when
we're off in the woods doing these these
marches and things like that we have to
practice but he carries like the
fireman's carry and things like that he
throws me around his neck you know I'm
like a towel he's just skipping down
like it's nothing and then I gotta put
him on me and I'm just like oh god die
and it was it was it was weirdly fun I I
enjoyed it but it was no good for my
body and so in a land navigation
movement I step off a log because I was
on point and on the other side of the
log because it's the woods in Georgia
I'm at Sand Hill
I see a snake and so in my memory you
know it's like time slows down because
North Carolina you know where I grew up
you think all snakes are poisonous sorry
there's an issue we know we're good it's
completely fine no we're fine I just
there was something that happened on the
screen I wanted to make sure it was okay
no that's just so by joining the chat
that's what I was worried about ii
opened up here yeah so anyway I try to
take a much longer step in midair I land
badly and it's it's just one leg is like
fire I'm limping I'm limping and
whipping but you know everybody says
don't go to sick call cuz you go to sick
call you lose your slot you'll end up
general infantry our regular infantry
and so I go back I just tough it out I
get my rack in the next morning when I
get out of the rack which is the the top
bunk bed right
I jump down in my legs they just give
out underneath me and I try to get up in
and I just can't get up and so I got a
sick call and I end up going to the
hospital and they end up x-ray and me
and they also x-rayed my battle buddy
because I gotta go there was somebody
else and he has a broken hip where they
had to bring him to surgery and it's in
the book there's a lot more detail about
it was kind of a dramatic moment but for
me they just said I had bilateral tibial
fractures right all the way up my legs
they said I had spiderwebs and the next
phase of the training was jump school
right where you gotta jump out of a
plane and the doctor you know I was like
son
if you jump on those legs they're gonna
turn into powder and he's like I can
hold you back you know we can put you
for like six months you stay off them
then you can go back through through the
whole cycle right start basic from
scratch but you'll lose your slot in the
special forces pipeline because of the
way these things are scheduled and
everything like that and then you'll
basically be reassigned to the needs of
the army or which probably meant I was
going back to IT which was what I joined
the army
kind of escape or you can go out on this
special kind of discharge that's called
an administrative discharge right
normally got honorable discharge
dishonorable discharge things like that
this is something for people who have
been in for I think less than six months
where it's like a mulling a marriage
it's as if it never happened is is if
you never joined and at the time I was
like well you know that's very kind of
him to do that
and I took it you know they they dissent
me to sit call or sorry the sickbay
where you're in like the medical platoon
and you do nothing for I think about a
month and then then they let you out
once the paperwork all finishes but in
hindsight I realized that if you take it
administrative discharge it exempts the
army for liability for your injuries so
actually what I thought was a kindness
was just you know now if I had future
problems with my legs they wouldn't have
to cover it or health insurance on any
of those things anyways it was just a
funny thing but anyway I get out of the
army and here I'm on crutches for a long
time and just sort of trying to figure
out all right well what's next in life
because I had gotten basic security
clearance just for going through signing
up for the military process I applied
for a security guard position at the
University of Maryland because it said
you had to get a top-secret clearance
which was with a higher clearance than I
had at time and I went well that sounds
good because I knew if I combine my IT
skills which were now suddenly much more
relevant again to my future with the
top-secret security clearance because of
the way it works if you have a
top-secret security clearance and tech
skills you get paid a ridiculous amount
of money for doing very little work so I
was like alright well you know I can
basically make twice what I would be
making in the private sector working for
government at this level at this phase
because what we talked about earlier
with September 11th and how the
intelligence community change they no
longer cared that I hadn't graduated
from college right and I had gotten
GED just by going in and taking a test
so for government purposes it was the
same as if I was a high school graduate
so now suddenly it was like these these
doors are open now this University of
Maryland facility turned out to be an
NSA facility it was called a castle the
center for the Advanced Study of
language at the University of Maryland
College Park and all I was was literally
a security guy walking around with with
a walkie-talkie making sure nobody
breaks in at night managing the
electronic alarm system and things like
that but once I had my foot in the door
there I could start climbing ladder step
by step and I applied for or I went to a
job fair actually that was only for
people who had security clearances and I
ended up going to the table for one of
the technical companies it was a little
tiny subcontractor nobody's ever heard
of and they said you know we've got tons
of positions for somebody like you
are you comfortable working nights and I
was like yeah you know I wake up in the
middle of day anyway that that's fine
with me
and suddenly I've gone from working for
the NSA through a university in a weird
way where it's like the NSA holds the
clearance but I'm formerly an employee
of the state of Maryland at the the
college and this is government man it's
all these weird dodges and boondoggles
for how people are employed there now
suddenly I'm working at CIA headquarters
right the place where all the movies
show you swoop over the marble seal and
everything like that I'm the king of the
castle right I'm there at the middle of
the night when no one else is there the
lights are on motion sensors it's the
creepiest thing in the world there's
like flags on the wall that are just
like gently billowing in the
air-conditioning like ghosts the hallway
lights up as you walk alongside it
because it's like a green building and
they disappear behind you and there's
there's no one there I can go down to
the gym at like 2:00 o'clock in the
morning at the CIA
and it's like not see a soul on the
other side of the building then go all
the way back and this kind of thing was
was my end because they were like look
it's the nightshift nothing that bad is
gonna happen um but it was on a very
senior technical team that was basically
handling systems administration for
everybody in the Washington Metropolitan
Area right so every basically CIA server
this is a computer system that like data
is stored on the reporting is stored on
that traffic is moved on all of this
stuff
suddenly me this is a circa 2005 I think
I'm in charge of and it's just me and
one other guy on the night shift and if
you're interested in the book there's a
lot of detail on this but I get sort of
scouted from this position because they
realize I actually know a lot about
technology they were expecting me just
to basically make sure the building
doesn't burn down all these systems
don't go down overnight and then never
come back up but they go well are you
willing to go overseas and to a young
man at that age that's actually like hey
that sounds kind of exciting you know
who doesn't want to go work overseas for
the CIA and there's a lot of people
listening the podcast who are like oh
not me wait the CIA's the bad guys right
yeah exactly they're like what are you
gonna go overthrow a government
somewhere but you have to understand
that I'm still very much a true believer
the government is like the living
compressed embodiment of truth and
goodness and light you know the shining
city on the hill so I want to do my part
to spread that to the world I didn't
have skepticism is really what I'm
trying to establish here and so I sign
up and I go through this special
training school like people hear in
movies about the farm which is down at
Camp Peary in Virginia I'm sent that's
actually much more secret facility
called the hill which is in Warrenton
Virginia and this is been covered a few
times and open-source media but I think
this is one of the few book length
discussions of what happens there in
permanent record
but yeah so I go through training and
then I get assigned overseas and I end
up in Geneva Switzerland
undercover as a diplomat right I think
I'm my formal title for the embassy is
like something super playing like
diplomatic attache and what I am is I'm
a forward deployed tech guy they send
you through this school to make you into
kind of a MacGyver right yes you can
handle all the computers but you can
also handle the connections for the
Embassy's Power Systems right the actual
electrical connections you can handle
the HVAC systems right you can handle
locks and alarms and security systems
basically anything that's got an on
button on it at the Embassy that's
secure now you're responsible for and I
traveled from Geneva to other countries
in Europe for sort of assignments and it
was like it was an exciting time I
actually still enjoyed it but this was
where I first working with intelligence
started to get doubts and the story's
been told many times so I won't go over
in full detail here but the CIA does
primarily and it's not the only thing
they do what's called human intelligence
now there are many different types of
intelligence than the intelligence
community is responsible for the primary
ones are human intelligence and signals
intelligence you want to think of
signals intelligence right as tapping
lines hacking computers all of these
sort of things that provide electronic
information anything that's digital or
analog signal that can be intercepted
then turned into information human
intelligence is you know all that fun
stuff we've heard the CI
for decades and decades which is where
they try to turn people basically they
say look we'll give you money if you
sell out your country they don't it's
not even your country a lot of times
it's your like organization these guys
could be working for a
telecommunications provider and they
want to sell customer records over they
worked at a bank which was the thing
that I saw and we wanted records on the
banks customers so he wanted a guy on
the inside but anyway that that's sort
of how it works and what I saw was they
were way more aggressive for the lowest
stakes than was reasonable or
responsible they were totally willing to
destroy somebody's life just on the off
chance they would get some information
that would that wouldn't even be a
tremendously valuable and so you know
ethically thatthat struck me as a bit
off but I let it pass because what I
what I've learned over my life short
though it's it's been you know it's that
skepticism is something that needs to
build up over time it's a skill
something that needs to be practiced or
you can think of it as something that
you developed through exposure I kind of
like a radiation poisoning but in a
positive way it's when you start to
realize inconsistencies or hypocrisy
that Ward lies and you notice them and
you know you you give somebody the
benefit of the doubt or you trust them
or you think it's all right but then
over time you see it's not an isolated
instance it's a pattern behavior and
over time that exposure to inconsistency
builds and builds and builds until it's
something that you can no longer ignore
now after the CIA I went to the NSA in
Japan where I was working there in Tokyo
and then from there a couple years later
I went to the CIA again now I was
working as a private employee for Dell
but I was the senior technical official
on Dells Sales Account the CIA
you know people these big companies they
have say
accounts to the CIA and so this means
I'm going in and now it's crazy because
I'm still a very young man but I'm
sitting across the table from Chiefs of
these enormous CIA divisions I'm sitting
across from their chief technology
officer for the entire agency or the
chief intelligent her chief information
officer for the entire CIA and these
guys are going look here's a problems
here's what we want to do and it's my
job to pitch them a system right and
I've got paired up with this sales guy
and the whole thing is just go how much
money can we get out of the government
right that's the whole goal and we'll
build them what we were pitching was a
private cloud system right everybody
knows about cloud computing now it's
like why your Gmail account is available
wherever you go it's why Facebook has
this massive system of records for
everyone everywhere the government
wanted to have these kind of
capabilities to Dell ended up getting
beat out by Amazon people well you know
some people aren't familiar with this
many of them are but Amazon runs a
secret cloud system for the government I
forget what they've rebranded it now but
this is just there's this massive
connection between industry and
government in the classified space that
just goes deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper but at this point I I was
already I had misgivings because of what
I'd seen in Japan about government but I
was just trying to get by I was trying
to ignore the conflicts I was trying to
ignore the inconsistencies and I think
this is a state that a lot of people in
these large institutions not just in our
country but around the world I struggle
with every day right there they got a
job they got a family they got bills
that they're just trying to get by and
they know that some of the things
they're doing are not good things they
know some of the things they're doing
are actively wrong but they know what
happens to people who rock the boat
eventually
I changed my mind and when I had gone to
Hawaii which was the final position in
my career with the intelligence
community I was because of an accident
of history here I wasn't supposed to be
in this position at all I was supposed
to be at a group called the national
threat Operations Center and talk but
because of the way contracting works and
again this is covered in the book I end
up being reassigned to this little
rinky-dink office that nobody's ever
heard of in the light called the Office
of information sharing and I'm replacing
this old-timer who's about to retire a
really really nice guy but he spent most
of his days just reading novels and
doing nothing and letting people be
content to the fact there are letting
people forget that his office existed
because he was the only one in it
there's there's a manager who's like
over him but it's actually over a larger
group and he just looks over him as sort
of a favor so now I come in and now I'm
the sole employee of the office of
information sharing but I'm not close
enough to retirement that I'm ok with
just doing nothing at all so I get in
business and I come up with this idea
for a new system called the heartbeat
and what the heartbeat is gonna do is
connect to basically every information
repository in the intelligence community
both at the NSA and across Network
boundaries which you normally can't
cross but because I've worked at both
the CIA and the NSA I knew the network
well enough both sides of it sides that
normal workers at the NSA would never
have seen because you have to be in one
or the other I could actually connect
these together I could build bridges
across this kind of network space and
then draw all of these or
records into a new kind of system that
was supposed to look at your digital ID
basically your your sort of ID card that
says this is who I am I work for this
agency I work in this office these are
my assignments these are my group
affiliations and because of that the
system would be able to eventually
aggregate records that were relevant to
your job that were related to you and
then it could provide them and basically
you could hit this site it would be an
update of what we used to call read
boards which were manually created there
we go look you work in network defense
right these are all the things that are
happening on a network defense you work
on I don't know economic takeovers in
Guatemala you know if this is what's
going on for you there but in my off
time I helped the team that sat next to
me which was a systems administration
team for a for Windows Networks because
I had been microsoft certified systems
engineer' which means basically I knew
how to take care of Windows networks and
this was all those guys did and they
always had way too much work way too
much work and I had basically no work
that I needed to do at all
because all I was supposed to do was
share information which was not
something that was particularly in
demand because most people already knew
what they wanted her what they needed so
it was basically my job was to sit there
and collect a paycheck unless I wanted
to get ambitious and so I did some side
gigs for these other guys and one of
them was running what were called dirty
word searches now dirty word searches
are let me let me dial this back because
I know we're sort of this is hard to
track everything that the NSA does in
large part is classified everything the
CIA does in large part is classified
if I made lunch plans with other people
in my office it was classified that was
the policy it's dumb they this over
classification problem is one of the
central flaws in government right now
this is the reason we don't understand
what they're doing this is why they can
get on wrong way this is why they can
get away with breaking the law or
violating our rights for so long you
know five years ten years fifteen fifty
years before they see before we see what
they were doing and it's because of this
routine classification right but every
system computer system has a limit on
what level of classified information is
supposed to be stored on it and we've
got all these complicated systems for
code words and caveats that establish a
system of what's called compartment
ation and this is the idea when you work
at the CIA when you work at the NSA
you're not supposed to know what's
happening in the office next to you
right because you don't have
need-to-know right again that thing from
the movies and the reason they have this
is they don't want one person to be able
to go and know everything Ryan tell
everybody everything they don't want
anybody to know too much particularly
when they're doing lots of bad things
because then there's the risk that you
realize they're doing so many bad things
that it's passed the point that we can
justify and they might develop sort of
an ideological objection to that well in
the office of information sharing and
actually in basically every part of my
career before that I had access to
everything I had what was called a
special caveat on my accesses called
protec which means privileged access
what this means you're kind of super
user you know most people have all of
these controls and the kind of
information that can access but I'm in
charge of the system right people who
need information they have to get it
from somewhere they don't know even the
director of the CIA right he says I need
to know everything about this well he
doesn't know where to get it he's just a
manager somebody has to be able to
actually cross these thresholds and get
those things
that guy was me and so dirty word
searches were these kind of automated
queries that I would set up to go across
the whole network and look at all of the
different levels of classification and
compartment ation and exceptionally
controlled information that's kind of
you could think of it as above top
secret in these special compartments
right where you're not even supposed to
know what these compartments are for you
only know the code word unless you work
in them unless you have access to them
unless you read into them one day I get
a hit on the dirty word search for a
program that I'd never heard of called
stellar wind it came back because the
the little caveat for they're called
handling caveats which is like you know
you can think of like Burn After Reading
or for your eyes only but this one's
called
STL W which means stellar wind unless
you know what stellar wind is you don't
know how to handle it all I knew is it
wasn't supposed to be on my system you
know this is a little bit unusual and it
turned out this document was placed on
the system because one of the employees
who had worked on this program years
before had come to Hawaii and this
person was a lawyer I believe and they
had worked in the inspector general's
office and they had compiled a report
part of the inspector general's report
which is when the government is
investigating itself into the operations
and activities of this program well this
was the domestic mass surveillance
program that I talked about in the very
beginning of our conversation that
started under the Bush White House
stellar wind was no longer supposed to
be really an operation it had been
unveiled in a big scandal in December
2005 in the New York Times by journalist
James risin and I I'm not gonna name him
because I don't want to get it wrong
another journalist you can look at the
byline
now if you want to see their involvement
but and there's there's a lot of history
here too but um what they had found was
of course the Bush White House had
constructed a warrantless wiretapping
program if you remember the warrantless
wiretapping scandal that was affecting
everyone in the United States well
the Bush White House was really put in a
difficult position by this scandal they
would have lost the election over this
scandal because the New York Times
actually had this story in October 2004
which was the election year they were
they were ready to go with it but at
this specific request of the White House
talking to the publisher of the New York
Times Saul's burger and Bill Keller than
the executive editor of the New York
Times the New York Times said we won't
run the story because the president just
said if you run this story a month
before the election that's very tight
margin if you recall you'll have blood
on your hands and it was so close to
2001 the New York Times just went you
know what fine Americans don't need to
know that the kind of sushis big
violator they don't need to know that
the Fourth Amendment doesn't mean what
they think it means if the government
says it's alright and it's a secret you
shouldn't know about it that's fine now
December 2005 why did that change why
did the New York Times has suddenly run
this story well it's because James Rison
the reporter who found this story had
written a book and he was about to
publish this book and the New York Times
was about to be in a very uncomfortable
position of having to explain why they
didn't run this story and how they got
scooped by their own journalists and so
they finally did it but it was too late
Bush had been reelected and now he was
sweeping up the broken glass of our lost
rights so Congress the bush White House
was very effective and as I said before
telling a very few select members of
Congress that this program existed
and they told them this program existed
in ways that they wouldn't object to but
made them culpable for hiding the
existence from the program the existence
of the program from the American people
and this is why someone like Nancy
Pelosi who you wouldn't exactly think
would be buddy-buddy with George Bush
was completely okay in defending this
kind of program in fact and you know
later she said oh well she had
objections to the program that she wrote
in a letter the White House but she
never showed us the letter she went on
well that was that was classified right
and this is not to bag on her
individually it's just she's a great
example in here an unnamed example
everyone knows of how this process works
the White House will implicate certain
very powerful members of Congress in
their own criminal activity and so on
when then when the White House gets in
trouble for it the Congress has to run
cover for the White House and so what
happened was Congress passed an
emergency law in 2007 called the protect
America Act now which should have been
our first indication this is a very bad
thing because they never named a law
something like that unless something
terrible and what it did was it
retroactively Lee immunized all of the
phone companies in the United States
that had been breaking the law millions
of times a day by handing your records
over to the government which they
weren't allowed to do simply on the
basis of a letter from the president
saying please do this and these
companies went look now that we've been
uncovered now that we've been shown that
we're breaking or now that these
journalists have shown that we've broken
the law and violated the rights of
Americans and a staggering scale that
could bankrupt our companies because we
can be sued for this we will no longer
cooperate with you unless you pass a law
that says people can't sue us for having
done this and so we get the Patek
tamerica Act which stays you know as an
emergency yeah this is all public
history - yeah you can look this up on
Wikipedia you know
and so then they they go it's an
emergency law we have to pass this now
we have to keep this program active Bush
is going to end the warrantless
wiretapping program and continue it
under this new authority where it's
gonna have some special level of
oversight and these kind of things
eventually but for now we just have to
make sure people are safe again they go
to fear they say if we don't have this
program terrorist attacks will continue
you know people will die blood on your
hands blood on your hands blundering
hands think of the children protect
America Act passes the companies get off
the hook the Bush White House gets off
the hook the Congress that was then
sharing in criminal culpability for
authorizing or rather letting these
things go by without stopping them then
passes in 2008 the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act Amendments of 2008 this
is called the the FAA 5-minutes Act of
2008 and rather than stopping all of the
unlawful and sort of unconstitutional
activities that the intelligence agency
was doing they continued it in different
ways simply by creating a few legal hubs
for them to jump through now this is not
to say you know these things aren't
helpful at all it's not say they're not
useful at all but it's important to
understand when the government's
response to any scandal then this
applies to any country is not to make
the activities of the person who is
caught breaking the law comply with the
law but instead make the activities of
the person who is breaking the law legal
right they make the law comply with what
the agencies want to do rather than
making the agencies comply with law
that's a problem and that's what
happened here
now the intelligence community's powers
actually grew in response to this
scandal in 2008 because Congress was on
the hook and they just wanted to move on
and get this
over with there were objections there
were people who knew this was a bad idea
but it didn't passed on now what the
public took away from this because a
part of these laws was a requirement
that the Inspector General of all of
these different intelligence community
elements and the Director of National
Intelligence submit a report saying this
is what happened under that warrantless
wiretapping program this is how it
complied with the law or how it didn't
comply with the law and basically look
back at how this program was constituted
what it did what the impacts and effects
were and that was supposed to be sort of
the Truth and Reconciliation Council
right now why am I talking about all
this ancient history well I'm sitting
here in 2012 with a classified Inspector
General's report draft report from the
NSA that names names that says Dick
Cheney it says David Addington this is
Nancy Pelosi that says all these people
who are involved in the program
the tick-tock of how it happens it says
the director of the NSA that guy who is
evacuating the building at the beginning
of our our our podcast here that guy was
asked by the President of the United
States if he would continue this program
after being told by the White House and
the Department of Justice that these
programs were not lawful that they were
not constitutional and the president
said would you continue this program on
my say-so alone knowing that it's risky
knowing that it's unlawful and he said
yes sir I will
if you think that's what's necessary to
keep the country safe and at that moment
I realize these guys don't care about
the law these guys don't care about the
Constitution these guys don't care about
the American people they care about the
continuity of government they care about
the state right and this is something
that people have lost we hear this
phrase over and over again national
security national security national
security and we're meant to interpret
that
to mean public safety but national
security is a very different thing from
public safety national security is a
thing that in previous generations we
referred to as state security national
security was a kind of term that came
out of the Bush administration to run
cover for the fact that we were
elevating a new kind of secret police
across the country and what does it mean
when again in a democracy in the United
States the public is not partner to
government the public does not hold the
leash of government anymore but we are
subject to government right we are
subordinate to government and we're not
even allowed to know that it happened no
not in in the book I tell the fact that
I had access to the unclassified version
of this report back in Japan and what's
interesting is the unclassified version
of a report and we've all seen this
today with things like the Muller report
and all of the intelligence reporting
that's happened in the last several
years when the government provides a
classified report to the public it's
normally the same document the
unclassified version the classified
version are the same thing
just the unclassified version has things
blacked out or redacted that they say oh
you're not allowed to know this sentence
for this paragraph or this page or
whatever the document that the public
had been given about the warrantless
wiretapping program was a completely
different document it was a document
tailor-made to deceive and mislead the
Congress and the public of the United
States and it was effective in doing
that and in 2012 what I realized was
this is what real-world conspiracies
look like right it doesn't have to be
smoking men behind closed doors right
it's lawyers and politicians it's
ordinary people from the working level
to the management level
who go if we don't explain this in a
certain way we're all gonna lose our
jobs or the other way they go we're
gonna get something out of this if we
all work together civilization is the
history of conspiracy right what what is
civilization but a conspiracy for all
all of us to do better by working
together right but it's this kind of
thing that I think too often we forget
because it's boring as hell I want all
your listeners right to go to the
Washington Post because this document
that I discovered that that really
changed me has been published courtesy
of The Washington Post
it's called the the inspector general's
report on on stellar wind and you can
look at the actual document that I saw
that was unredacted right I had no
blacked-out pages on mine and what I
believe it shows is that some of the
most senior officials in the United
States elected and unelected worked
together to actively undermine the
rights of the American people to give
themselves expanded powers now in their
defense they said they were seeking
these powers for a good and just and
noble cause right they say they were
trying to keep us safe but that's what
they always say that's what every
government says that's no different than
what the Chinese government says or the
Russian government says and the question
is if they are truly keeping us safe why
wouldn't they simply just tell us that
well why wouldn't they have that debate
in Congress why wouldn't they put that
to a vote because if they were and they
could convince us that they were they'd
win the vote and particularly we all
know like the Patriot Act passed more
the worst pieces of legislation in
modern history passed why didn't we get
a vote and I think if you read the
report the answer we clear so I'm sorry
Joe I went on for various no is amazing
it's act don't don't apologize at all
it's just completely fascinating that
the continuation of this policy came
down to one man and the president having
this discussion that is so well it's
it's much it's much more much more but
right right literally the president at
the heart of it yes at the heart of it
in every expression of executive power
right and by executive we mean the White
House here the CIA the NSA the FBI
the DOJ right beat these guys exist as a
part of the executive branch of
government in a real way they work for
the White House now there are laws and
regulations and policies that are
supposed to say they're supposed to do
this and they're supposed to say they're
not supposed to do that but when you
look at federal regulations when you
look at policies as an employee of
government when you violate these
policies the worst thing that happens to
you is you lose your job because there's
no criminal penalty for the violation of
these laws and so it's very easy for
people who exist in these structures
particularly the very top levels of
these structures to go look we have a
given set of lawful authorities and
these are defined very broadly to give
us leeway to do whatever it is we think
is proper and appropriate and just now
take that proper inappropriate and just
from the perspective of any given
individual Ryan any given president now
intersect that with what's good for them
politically and that's where problems
begin to arise now the safety measure
that's supposed to protect us from this
in the u.s. system in a democracy
broadly is these people are supposed to
be what are called public officials that
means we know their decisions that means
we know their policies that means we
know their programs and prerogatives and
powers like what they are doing both in
our name and what they're doing against
us and because they are transparent to
us
we the people can then police their
activities we can go and disagree with
this we can protest it
we can't campaign against and write we
can try to become the president do
whatever they are public officials and
we are private citizens they're not
supposed to know anything about us right
because we in relative terms hold no
power and they hold all the power so
they have to be under the tightest
constraints we need to be in the freest
circumstances and yet the rise of the
state-secrets doctrine right this whole
classification system that goes all the
way back to last century about the
middle of the last century I believe is
is when it really started getting tested
in court and I think you know more about
this in many cases than I do when you
start talking about what happened in the
FBI and the CIA and the NSA is sort of
old dirty work in the the 20th century
is they abused their powers repeatedly
and continuously they did active harm to
domestic politics in the United States
the FBI was spying on Martin Luther King
and trying to get Martin Luther King to
kill himself before the Nobel Prize was
going to be awarded in fact after MLK
gave his I have a dream speech two days
later the FBI classified him is the
greatest national or I think it was the
greatest national security threat in the
United States and yet this is the FBI
this is the the group that everybody's
applauding today saying all these these
wonderful Patriots and heroes now I'm
not saying everybody the FBI is bad
I'm not saying anybody everybody the CIA
and the NSA is bad I'm saying that you
don't become patriot based on where you
work
patriotism is not about a loyalty to
government patriotism in fact it's not
about loyalty to anything patriotism is
a constant effort to do good for the P
of your country right it's not about the
government it's not about the state and
this is well we'll get into loyalty
later because you know I think one of
the big criticisms against me there
should be talked about is um they go
look this guy is disloyal he broke an
oath he did whatever a loyalty loyalty
is a good thing when it's in the service
of something good but it is only good
when it's in the service of something
good if you're loyal to a bad person if
you're loyal to a bad program if you're
loyal to a bad government
that loyalty is actively harmful and I
think that's overlooked but yeah when
you get back into this whole thing about
sort of where it came from why it
happened how it could come out of just
this small group and then they could
slowly kind of poison by implication by
complicity by bringing them into the
conspiracy and then having them not say
anything about it a wider and wider
broad a body of people and then once
you've got enough people in on it it's
much easier to convince other people
that it's legitimate because they can go
look we've got 30 people who know about
this and none of them have objected to
it why are you gonna object to this all
of this derives from that original sin
which is in a democracy creating a
system of government that is in fact a
secret government a body of secret law
body of secret policy that is far beyond
what legitimate government secrets could
be this is not saying like government
hasn't can have no secrecy at all if the
government wants to investigate someone
without having them respond right we're
talking traditional law enforcement sure
you're not gonna tell this mobster hey
you know we're gonna start investigating
you we the public don't need to know the
names of every terrorist suspect out in
the world right but we do need to know
again the powers and programs the
policies that a government is asserting
at least the broad outlines of it
because otherwise how can we control it
how do we know if the government is a
it's authorities that are supposed to be
granted to it by us if we don't know
what it is that they're doing and so
this is the the main thing and really
the story behind the title permanent
record is look Joe when you were a kid
you know when I was a kid when you were
a teenager riling what's the worst thing
you've ever said you know did you say
anything you weren't proud did you do
anything that you weren't proud of
something that today in like the whoa
kissed of Twitter land you would get in
trouble for I'm sure and that's one of
the horrible things about kids growing
up today is that they do have all this
stuff out there on social media forever
and they can be judged horribly by
something they did when they were 13
it's exactly that our worst mistakes our
deepest shames were forgotten right they
were lost they were ephemeral even the
things we did get caught for they were
known for a time maybe they're still
remembered by people who are closest to
us whether we like them or dislike them
but they were people connected to us now
we're forced to live in a real way naked
before power whether we're talking about
Facebook whether we're talking about
Google whether we're talking about the
government of any country they know
everything about us or much about us
rather and we know very little about
them and we're not allowed to know more
everything that we do now lasts forever
not because we want to remember but
because we're not allowed to forget just
carrying a phone in your pocket is
enough for your movements to be
memorialized because every cell phone
tower that you pass is keeping a record
of that and 18t keeps those records
going back to 2008 under program called
Hemisphere if you search for Hemisphere
and AT&T you'll get a story in The Daily
Beast about it 18 he keeps your phone
records going back to 1983
if any year listeners were born after
1983 right born after me or it might be
1987 excuse me 1987 if they're born
after 1987 and they're 18 is he customer
or their calls cross 18 days network
ATMs he has every phone call they ever
made rather the record that had happened
not necessarily the contents on the
phone call um and so I mean let me turn
this around for you Joe cuz I feel like
I've just been given a given of speech
when you look at this stuff right when
you look at what's happening with
government when you look at what's
happening with the Trump White House the
Obama White House the Bush White House
you could see this trend happening when
you look at what's happening with
Facebook when you look at what's
happening with Google when you look the
fact that you go to every restaurant
today and you see people look at the
phones you know you get on a bus you get
on a subway you know you see somebody
sitting next to you in traffic you see
people looking at phones these devices
are connected all the time now people
are getting Alexa right now now people
have okay Google they have you know Siri
on their phones that are in their house
they've always got these connected
microphones where do you think this
leads and what is it that gives you sort
of trust in the system faith in the
system like how just-just-just so we can
start a conversation here what strikes
you about this well it's completely
alien and it's new this is something
that's unprecedented we don't have a
long human history of being completely
connected via technology this is
something we're navigating right now for
the first time and it's probably the
most powerful thing that the human race
has ever seen in terms of the
distribution of information there's
nothing that even comes close to it in
all of human history and we're figuring
it out as we go along
and what you exposed is that not only
are we figuring out as we go along but
that to cover their ass
these cellphone companies in cahoots
with the government have made it legal
for them to gather up all of your phone
calls all of your text messages all of
your emails and store them somewhere so
that retroactive Lee if you ever say
anything they don't like or do something
they don't like they can go back find
that and use it against you and we don't
know who they are we don't know why
they're doing it and we didn't know they
could do it until you exposed it the the
connection of human beings via
technology is is both amazing and
powerful and incredible in terms of our
access to knowledge but terrifying in
terms of the government's ability to
track our movements track your phone
calls track everything and under the
guise of protecting us from terrorists
and protecting us from sleeper cells
protecting us from attacks look if they
really are attacked protecting us from
these attacks that's great but there's
there's no provision in the Constitution
that allows any of this and this is
where it gets really squirrely because
they're making up the rules as they go
along and they're making up these rules
the way you're describing it this is
step by step this has happened to sort
of protect their ass and keep themselves
from being implicated in what has been a
violation of our rights and our
privacy's and the Fourth Amendment yeah
I mean I I think I think one of the
things that everybody needs to
understand when you look at these things
and the reason you know we talked about
before when I got this information why I
didn't just put it on the internet and
people criticize me for this they go I
didn't share enough information because
the journalists are gatekeeping right
they've got a big archive and they
haven't published everything from it and
I told them not to publish everything
why did you do that why did you do that
because so again I get back to
legitimate secrets an illegitimate
secrets um some spying from my
perspective you know career spy is okay
right
agreed if you have hacked a terrorists
phone right and you're getting some
information about that useful agreed
yeah if you're spying on a Russian
general in charge of a you know rocket
division useful right but there there
are lines and degrees in that where it's
not useful now the examples that I just
gave you these are
targeted this is where you're spying on
an individual there no named person that
is being monitored for a specific reason
that is related hopefully from a warrant
people write well even for foreign
intelligence and some indications you
don't need a warrant
strictly although I think they should
have warrants for all of these
investigations because they established
a court for precisely this reason called
the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Court right yeah and there's not a judge
in the world who wouldn't stamp a
warrant saying hey spy on Abu jihad over
here right and if you want to spy on
another guy Boris badenov with the
rocket division right that that's okay
they're gonna go with that but then you
look at these edge cases and in the
archive that I provided to journalists
that meant stories that have come down
where they've spied on journalists right
they've spied on human rights groups and
these kind of things I think people miss
I'm gonna throw up some slides here so
forgive me if this gets weird and I put
up the wrong ones but since I came
forward this Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court that the government
says authorized these programs 15
different times was overruled by the
first open courts to look at the program
these are federal courts here right that
said no actually these programs are
unlawful they're likely unconstitutional
when you start looking at the facts you
see even within the context of the very
loose restrictions and laws that apply
to the NSA and surveillance they say
they broke their own laws you know two
thousand seven hundred and seventy six
times in a single year and then you
asked about that thing that motivates me
like why I came forward we had been
trying as a country before I came
forward to prove the existence of these
programs legally because this is our
this is our means of last sort of
recourse in our system right we get the
executive we got the legislature we got
right so Congress makes the laws the
executives supposed to carry them out
the courts are supposed to play referee
the executive had broken the laws
Congress was turning a blind eye to the
laws and the courts were and this is
just months before I came forward going
well it does appear that the ACLU and
Amnesty International like all of these
human rights groups and non-governmental
organizations had established that you
know these programs are likely unlawful
they likely exist they're simply
classified but the government responded
with this argument that you just saw
saying that well it's a state secret if
they do exist you the plaintiffs don't
have hard concrete evidence that they do
exist and the government is saying
legally you have no right to discover
evidence from the government right
documents demand documents or demand an
answer from the government as to whether
things these as to whether or not these
things exist because the government's
just gonna give its standard what they
called Glomar response we can neither
confirm nor deny that these things exist
which leaves you out in the cold which
leaves the courts out in the cold the
courts go look the government could be
breaking along here look they could be
violating the Constitution here but
because you can't prove it and because
the government doesn't wanna play ball
and the government says if we were doing
this it would be legal and it would be
necessary for national security or
whatever the court can't presume to know
national security better than the
executive because the courts aren't
elected and so this leads to this
fundamentally broken system where okay
if the only way to have the courts
review the legality of the programs is
to establish the programs exist but the
programs are classified so you can't
establish they exist unless you have
evidence but providing that evidence to
courts to journalists to anyone is a
felony right that's punishable by 10
years per count
the Espionage Act and the government has
charged every a source of Public
Interest journalism who's really made a
significant difference in these kind of
cases since Daniel Ellsberg really going
back to that under the same Espionage
Act it's always the same law and this is
there's no distinction to government
between whether you've sold information
to a foreign government for private
benefit right or whether you provide an
information only to journalists for the
public interest and then that's a
fundamentally harmful thing I think when
you look at things that have come in the
wake of this we're talking about the the
post 2013 court rulings that found what
the government was doing was unlawful
you see the courts saying actually that
leaks or air quotes leaks can actually
be beneficial leak is used in the
government's and this you know this is
from a federal court these are not
exactly my biggest supporters they are
recognizing that although leak implies
harm it implies something that's broken
it's actually helpful it's a leak that's
letting in daylight in this context that
is the only thing that allows the system
to operate in a context where one year
before I came forward
we had the NSA saying this kind of stuff
didn't happen
we had hang on this famous exchange
which more than anything
made me realize this was a point of no
return because I've told you this you've
heard this but if you haven't seen it
you might not believe me right maybe I'm
a sketchy guy whatever one of those
senators I told you that objected to
this stuff that was doing the lassie
barks for all those years
Ron Wyden was confronting the most
senior spy in the United States a
General James clapper who was then the
Director of National Intelligence right
there's no guy higher than him the buck
stops with him when it comes to
intelligence he's testifying under oath
in front of Congress right but more
broadly in front of the
public this is televised and ron wyden
asked him a very specific question about
a program mind you that ron wyden knows
exists because he has security clearance
he sits on the Intelligence Committee
and he knows there's domestic mass
surveillance and this is how it goes
this is how the top spy responds under
oath so what I wanted to see is if you
could give me a yes or no answer to the
question does the NSA collect any type
of data at all on millions or hundreds
of millions of Americans no sir it does
not
not wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly so that was a lie
Wyden knew it was a lie clapper knew it
was a lie he actually admitted it was a
lie after I came forward you know three
months later but he said it was the
least untruthful thing he could think of
to say in the context of being in the
hot seat there but what does it mean for
a democracy when you can lie under oath
to Congress and the congressman even
knows you're lying to them but they're
afraid to correct you and widened by the
way it wasn't a surprise Wyden gave him
those questions twenty-four hours in
advance and he wrote a letter afterwards
asking for clapper to amend his
testimony right now not even at a press
conference but just to say this was
incorrect whatever so he could go
through the legal process and show his
fellow congressmen that there was a
problem and they needed to do it but all
of that was refused to us all of it was
denied to us and Here I am sitting at
the NSA next to my buddies who I've
talked to about these programs you know
I've gone look at this and they're
laughing at it you know I'm laughing at
it and it's not it's not that we go oh
ha ha ha he's getting away with it it's
like what are you gonna do these guys
are you know they're they're
bullshitters that the system is built
online
that even many people many experts who
have studied this know are lies but if
you can't prove their lies how do you
move beyond that and that's really a
question that has never been more
relevant than I think it is today under
the current White House so you're in
this position where you have this
information and you know that these
surveillance systems are in place and
they're unconstitutional and you feel
this deep responsibility to let the
American people know about this what
what makes you take the leap so this is
covered extensively in the book because
it took a long time I would imagine
people people you know yeah right
exactly people like to think it's like a
cinematic moment where I find this
golden document like this stellar wind
report and that's the closest thing to a
smoking gun right that exists but look
if you found that you you can read that
later look at that and like imagine
yourself being like oh I'm gonna go
outside on the courthouse steps and wave
this thing burn my life to the ground
burn my family to the ground I'm never
going to be work again I'm going to jail
for the rest of my life the question is
what would it take for you to light a
match and burn your life to the ground
too long the answer was nothing and I'm
ashamed of that it took me so long to
get over that home because I was waiting
for somebody else to do it when I saw
people like Ron Wyden on this when I saw
people like the court case that I showed
before where people were actively
challenging these programs right
journalists had the scent of it and you
know there are a lot of people who are
gonna be in the you knows of the YouTube
comments or whatever go oh I knew this
was happening no you didn't well Bill
bimini you had he bill Binney he built
built excuse me bill Binney he initially
was the one that came out and spoke
about
this issue and so yeah bill Benny is a
part of shall we say the group of early
NSA whistleblowers who came with Thomas
Drake bill Benny Kirk Wiebe I believe in
Edie Loomis and these guys all got their
doors kicked and you know they got
harassed by the FBI Tom Drake who was a
senior executive at the NSA this is a
guy who had a lot to lose was charged
under the same law was the Espionage Act
and these guys were doing it earlier
during the Bush administration some of
them were talking to the journalists
that in you know maybe it's alleged I
don't want to put them on the spot maybe
they deny it maybe they don't leave that
to them but somebody somewhere was
informing this reporting right that got
into the New York Times about the Bush
era warrantless wiretapping program and
eventually journalists put this out
there people knew these capabilities
existed but yeah then there's the person
in the YouTube comments so it's like oh
we knew all about this is nothing new
and the thing is you can know about some
programs and not know about others you
can have a suspicion you can know with a
certainty that this stuff is capable or
it is possible to capability exists you
can know that the government has done
this stuff in the past you can know they
are likely to do it again you can have
all these indications you can have like
the jewel versus NSA case that's run by
the e FF which is about the eighteen or
it's about AT&T
setting up secret rooms in their
telecommunications facilities where they
basically drag all the fibers for their
domestic Internet communications and
like phone communications into a room
that's purpose-built for the NSA and
then they bring it out but AT&T Nuys
it's the NSA the NSA denies that these
things happen or that are done at all
right and so this is the context I you
say you know and you know let's put it
the other way maybe you do know right
maybe you are an academic researcher
maybe your technological specialist
maybe you're just somebody who reads all
the reporting and you actually know you
can't prove it but you know this is
going on but that's the thing in a
democracy the distance
between speculation and fact the
distance between what you know and what
you can prove to everybody else in the
country is everything in our model of
government because what you know doesn't
matter what matters is what we all know
and the only way we can all know it is
if somebody can prove it if you can
prove it and if you don't have the
evidence you can't prove it and of
course when we talk about the earlier
stuff right like this or more
corporatized media they've got a
thousand incentives not to get involved
in this stuff they need access to the
White House they need these officials to
sit down with them and give interviews
right that's constant content that they
need that's access that they need they
need to be taken seriously they need to
be a you know admitted to briefers it is
a codependent relationship and yet
rather and so the only way to make sure
people understand this broadly is if we
all work together all right
if we collectively can establish a
corpus of evidence right a body of facts
that is so large and so persuasive it
overcomes the natural and understandable
resistance of these more corporatized
media groups it overcomes the political
and partisan sort of loyalties that that
all of these political factions in the
country do where they go you know it's
it's my president even if I don't like
this stuff even if I don't agree with
this stuff I don't want to say it exists
I want to deny it until it's proved you
know in HD on video you know signing the
order to do this that or the other
because otherwise this is a chance my
guy might not get reelected and that's
the only way this kind of stuff can
happen and the sad fact is the
opportunities that we have to prove this
like the the moments in history where we
do prove something anything beyond a
reasonable doubt are so few and so rare
that they almost always only come from
whistleblowers and I think that's
one of the problems that we have
particularly in that the climate
movement did look go ahead I'm sorry did
you take any comfort from knowing that
Obama when he was running for office and
in his hope and change website he had
provisions to protect whistleblowers and
provisions to to reward people right I
mean do you remember all that I mean it
was eventually redacted or eventually
deleted it from the website from yes but
that was a big part of his program or
what he was running on was that when
people were exposing unlawful activity
he was going to protect those people did
that did you take any comfort in this
one campaigned well Obama also during
his campaign said he campaigned actively
against the warrantless wiretapping the
bush ministration because remember
Bush's in the scandal in the height of
this on 2007 you know the elections
coming up right after and he's going oh
bomb Assange uh you know that's not who
we are right not what we do and yet
within a hundred days of him becoming
president now he's sitting in that chair
rather than extinguishing these programs
he embraces them and expands why do you
think that is more entrenched I think
it's actually again what we talked about
earlier first thing every time a new
president comes into the White House
they get their clearances right they get
read into all this stuff during the
campaign they get clearance isn't to get
rid of that stuff but when they find the
president right now they're the only
people who can sign what these are
called the covert action findings and
things like that which are basically you
know the intelligence community wants to
assassinate somebody they want to run
this illegal program here there or
everywhere and they can't do it because
their executive agencies without that
top level executive sign-off fine so
they got to open the vest right they got
to get these guys on on side
and basically every president since
Kennedy they have been successful in
what they call fearing up where as soon
as they come in
they lead you read you the litany of
Horrible's and they go these are all the
threats that we're facing and let's be
real it is a dangerous world it's not
just all made-up BS some of it is right
where it's inflated it's not that it's
completely false but they make it sound
more serious than it actually is but
there are real bad people out there who
are trying to do real bad things and you
have just gone through a hellish
election because our our electoral
politics are so diseased and now after
you've crawled through fire you're
already thinking four years ahead you
know how how do I stay in this seat and
these guys are basically saying if you
don't do X Y & Z this is gonna fall on
your lap and the implication which I
don't think they actually say but every
president knows is these guys can
undermine you to death if you've got the
ISEE against you right they can
Stonewall you they can put out stories
that are gonna be problematic for you
every day your presidency and it's not
that it's necessarily gonna gonna catch
you out of the White House but it's a
problem that as president you very much
don't want so in the most charitable
interpretation of this you've got a new
guy coming in in Obama's case this is a
pretty young guy doesn't focus in this
kind of national security foreign policy
stuff throughout his earlier career he's
more interested in domestic policy and
always has been that's actually one of
the positive things to say about Barack
Obama he's just trying to make things
better at home and now suddenly they go
look you need to worry about this
country you need to worry about this
group that you've never heard of you
need to worry about you know this
technology you need to do all this stuff
and the only reason we can tell you this
stuff and the only thing dividing
America and the abyss are these terrible
terrible terrible terror
programs right that are in fact
wonderful things because they keep back
the darkness and so here's here's the
real problem every president hears that
and every president you know first off
they've got so many other things do is
they just kind of nod their head and
they'll go I'll deal with this later in
my administration and this is one of the
ironies when I come came forward in 2013
right this is now Barack Obama's second
term president one of the responses that
they had to the mass surveillance of the
scandal was yes we think they went a
little too far this is after the initial
thing where they went nobody's listening
to your phone calls you know just made a
data right nobody nobody can have a
perfect privacy and also have perfect
security so we got to sort of divide a
line here between the Constitution and
you know what the government wants to do
but they said we were gonna get to it we
knew these programs were problematic but
if they just gave us more time we would
have fixed them maybe it's true right
seems awful convenient in hindsight that
throughout the entirety the first time
well it seems like what you would say if
you got caught right right right but
look in if we're being the most generous
that we are here the president is
briefed on real and legitimate threats
and they scare the hell out of them I'm
sure and we can we can all imagine being
there right those those of us who
remember what the world was like post
9/11 fear is a powerful thing but the
guys who are doing that briefing they're
no longer scared of it because they've
been dealing with this for years this is
the oldest thing they've given this
briefing times before you know when we
talk about people talk about the deep
state right they talk about it like some
conspiracy of lizard people it's not
that it's something much simpler the
deep state is simply the career
government it's the people who are in
the same offices who outlive and outlast
presidents is right they've seen
Republicans they've seen Democrats they
don't really care
and they give that same briefing again
and again and they get good at it they
know what they want they know what this
person saying where's the president they
don't know who these people are these
people who've been there before the
president they're gonna be there after
the president and so they give this very
effective very fear inducing speech and
then they followed up with their asks
which are really demands just politely
provided and anyone in that position who
is not an expert on this stuff who is
not ready for this sort of trade off and
who you have to understand is a career
politician is entirely used to the horse
trading game Rango and I'll deal with
this later or not now or what are the
this the cost-benefit here and the
intelligence community goes if you give
us what we want no one will ever know
about it because it's classified it's
obviously the easy answer and maybe
Barack Obama and honestly did want to
get to this later but what we can say
today is for all the good that may have
been done in that White House this is an
issue where the president went through
two full terms and did not fix the
problem but in fact made it worse well
it seems like the president has a job
it's absolutely impossible and if you
come across someone who has been in the
position like you know someone who's the
head of an intelligence agency for a
long time and it's very persuasive and
has some you know legitimate credentials
that show that he's very good at his job
but he tells you this is important for
national security we need to keep these
things in place it doesn't seem like any
one person can run the country and be
aware of every single program that every
single agency is implementing it seems
completely unrealistic and the the job
itself it just it doesn't seem like any
person can do it adequately and when it
comes to something like this mass
surveillance state I could see a
president being persuaded by someone who
comes to him and says this is why we
need to do this yeah I mean
one of the things that I think is the
underlying problem and everything that
you just described as the president has
too much power right and because they
have too much power that means they have
too much responsibility and I I don't
think people understand if they haven't
lived outside the United States if they
haven't sort of traveled or studied
broadly just how exceptional the
American presidency is most countries
don't have a single individual with this
level of power it's really only the
super States and and that may be by
design perhaps that's why they're
they're super States but when we look at
sort of complex advanced democracies
that are more peaceful they tend to have
a more multilateral system that has more
people involved in smaller portfolios
and a lot of this derives from just the
size of the government like you said you
know the president is responsible for
basically everything executive branch
and the executive branch is basically
every agency that actually doesn't work
and so how do you how do you correct for
that without breaking it up where you
have smaller ministers and ministries
and things like that that have different
levels of responsibility having a
smaller government overall you know back
in 1776 the federal government you know
was pretty much a dream
we weren't even interested in having
standing armies the idea of an army that
existed from year to year was terrifying
forbidding thing and then when you move
to this idea that we have a president
that they have these extraordinary
powers it's okay because the
government's very small the federal
government especially is seen as sort of
this small and toothless and weak thing
keep pause for one second is Spain pause
for one second because my ear pods are
about to die and I'm gonna swap over to
another pair these these suckers are
good for a couple hours but we're two
hours and 15 minutes here we'll have a
little bit of a weird audio issue with
the last half of it but Jamie Jamie I'll
take care of it I wanted to talk about
you like where you are right now in your
life and how your hand
this cuz you've been in exile for how
many years now it's been more than six
years six six years of 2013 yeah I mean
well actually I left May so what is life
like I mean are you in constant hiding I
mean what what are the issues like in in
the beginning my operational security
level as we would call it was was very
high I was concerned about being
recognized was concerned about being
followed I was concerned really about
very bad things happening to me because
the the government made it very clear
that from their position I was the most
wanted man in the world they literally
brought down the president of Bolivia
his aircraft and would not let it depart
as it tried to cross the airspace of
Europe not even the United States they
wouldn't let it leave until they
confirmed I was not on board so yeah
that made me a little bit nervous but
you can't live like that forever and
although I was as careful as I could be
my still lived pretty happily because I
was an indoor cat to begin with right
I've always been a technologist I've
always been pretty nerdy so as long as I
have a screen an internet connection I
was pretty happy but in the years past
my life has become more and more open
you know now I speak openly I live
openly I go out I ride the Metro I go to
restaurants like you know how often II
recognized so this is a funny thing as
I'm almost never recognized one of those
things is I don't give Russian
interviews because I don't want my face
all over the news which is nice because
it just allows people to sort of forget
about my face and I can go about my life
but I it's one of the weird things that
I'm recognized a couple times a year
even when I'm not wearing my glasses in
a museum or a grocery store or something
like that or out on the street
just by somebody who I swear like these
people are you might have read a story
about them like super recognizers the
people just have a great memory for
faces yeah because I can be like ooh Oh
wearing a hood and like a jacket it can
have a scarf around my face like in the
winter and it like you can barely see my
face and they'll come up to me and
they're like are you Snowden and I'm
like whoa that's what he uses pretty
impressive I'd say yeah it's nice to
meet you
and yeah they've it's I've never had a
negative interaction from being
recognized but for me none because I'm a
privacy advocate like I would much
rather go unrecognized like I don't want
to be a celebrity but the other thing is
I'll get recognized in computer stores
and I think there's just like a mental
Association where people are like their
brain when it's cycling through faces
that it recognizes it's going through
like the subset of nerdier people or
something like that when you're in a
computer store because for whatever
reason I'm recognized much more
frequently when there's some kind of
technological like locusts hmm so you're
living freely did you had to learn
Russian did you learn it yeah me my my
Russian is still pretty crappy to talk
to my great shame because all of my life
all of my work is primarily aimed right
right no you've talked about returning
home if you could get a fair trial is is
that a feasible thing a fair trial for
someone like you is that such a well is
that yeah that even possible question I
mean look if we're being Frank III I
think all your audience knows the chance
of me getting a fair shake in the
Eastern District of Virginia a couple
miles from the headquarters of the CIA
is probably pretty slim because that's
where they draw the jury pool from right
but my objection here is on a larger
print
right what what happens to me is less
important right if I spend the rest of
my life in jail that that's less
important then what I'm actually
requiring the government to agree to
which is a single thing right they say
face the music face the music and I'm
saying great let's pick the song the
thing is the law that I've been charged
under the one that all these
whistleblowers have been charged owner
Thomas Drake Daniel Ellsberg Chelsea
Manning Daniel Hale the drone
whistleblower who is in prison right now
going through a trial that is precisely
similar to what I would be facing his
lawyer is asking the court or telling
the court that we want to tell the jury
why he did what he did that the
government is violating the laws a
government is violating human rights
that these programs are immoral that
they're unethical this is what motivated
this guy to do it and the jury should be
able to hear why he did what he did and
the jury should be able to decide
whether that was right or wrong and the
government has responded you know to
this whistleblower argument basically
saying we demand the court forbid this
guy from breathing the word
whistleblower in court he cannot talk
about what motivated him he cannot talk
about what was revealed why it was
revealed what the impacts and effects
were if he can't talk about whether the
public benefited from it or was harmed
by it because it doesn't matter now this
might surprise a lot of people because
to a lot of us we think that's what a
jury trial is we think that's what a
fair trial is but the Espionage Act that
the government uses against
whistleblowers meaning broadly here the
sources of journalism is fairly unique
in the legal system in that it is what's
called a strict liability crime a strict
liability crime is what the government
considers to be basically a crime worse
than murder because if you if you
murdered somebody like if you just don't
know beat Jamie with the microphone
stand right now
you would be able to go to the court and
say it was self-defense
right yeah you you you felt threatened
you were in danger for your life even if
you weren't right even you obviously
weren't even if you were on tape you
could still argue that and the jury
could go you full of crap right and they
could convict you but if you were in
fact acting in self-defense if the jury
did in fact believe you they could take
that into consideration in establishing
their verdict
right strict liability crime forbid then
the jury is not allowed to consider why
you committed a crime they're only
allowed to consider if you committed a
crime they are not allowed to consider
if the murder was justified they are
only allowed to consider if the murder
took place and the funny thing in this
case is that the murder that we're
talking about is telling the truth the
Espionage Act in every case is a law the
government exclusively uses against
people who told the truth right like
that that's what it's about in the
context of journalism they don't bring
the Espionage Act against people who
lied then they would use fraud or some
other statute they say the government is
arguing in the context of whistleblowing
the telling a telling a important truth
to the American people by way of a
journalist is a crime worse than murder
and I believe and I think most Americans
would agree this is fundamentally in
defensively wrong and so my whole
argument with the United States
government since the very beginning was
been I'll be back for a jury trial
tomorrow but you have to agree to permit
whistleblowers a public interest offense
it doesn't matter whether they are
whistleblower or not it's just they
argued it's the jury that decides
whether they are always will blower or
not if they have to be able to consider
the motivations of why someone did what
they did the government says we refuse
to allow that because that puts the
government on trial and we don't trust
the jury to consider those questions Wow
so you have had these conversations then
so this has been discussed no this is
this is from the Obama administration
there's been no contact since since the
Trump administration because the
government basically when they got to
this point they went we have no good
argument against this and we will never
permit this to happen and again I just
want to make clear this is not
speculation this is not me thinking this
is actively happening in the case of
Daniel Hale right now I hope you guys
can pull up a graphic for because this
story just the papers like two or three
weeks ago saying the government is
forbidding this guy from from making
this argument so you're sitting in a
state of limbo then you're they're not
actively pursuing you it seems that if
you're able to move around freely they
they haven't discovered where you are
you're just free to live your life you
well yeah it's one of these things where
you know whether they know where I am or
whether they don't know where I am where
I put my head on the pillow doesn't
matter so much I'm in Russia right and
and we should lean into that because I
think people they hear Russia
particularly in the context of today's
news and you see like what people are
saying about tulsi gabbard and things
like yeah any kind of Association any
any time your name appears in the same
sentence in paragraphs same story is the
word Russia it's considered a negative
thing now yeah and don't get me wrong
I've been a longtime critic of the
Russian government
I just actually had a major story
written about me in a Russian state news
outlet called RIA Novosti you guys could
probably pull it it's only in Russian
though that's saying because I spoke
favorably about a member of the Russian
opposition Alexei Navalny which I wasn't
even speaking positively about this guy
I was saying look I think people have a
right to express their opposition in a
country and they should be able to do
that without fearing retaliation in the
future because the background here is
this this opposition figure has been a
long time
in the Russian administration side and
they've just suddenly magically been
accused of being foreign agents or
something like that and so everyone
connected to this which is like a big
civil society body I had their doors
like simultaneously kicked in across the
country and they're being investigated
for some kind of corruption or something
indeed doesn't even matter and you know
I I said I opposed that just like I was
tweeting you know footage of ballot
stuffing in the Russian elections just
like I've criticized the Russian
president my name I've criticized
Russian surveillance laws so many things
again and again and again and again and
again but yeah so look it does not make
my life easier to be trapped in a
country that I did not choose and people
don't remember this I was actually on
route to Latin America when the US
government canceled my passport which
trapped me in Russia and for those who
are interested again I wrote an entire
book that has a lot of detail on this
but yeah it's difficult to be basically
engaged in civil opposition to policies
of the United States government at the
same time as the Russian government and
it's it's a hard thing you know a it's
not a happy thing but I feel like it's a
necessary thing the problem is nobody
wants to talk about that nobody wants to
engage in that kind of nuance nobody
wants to consider it those kind of
conversations in the current world
people believe and this sexy were the
worst things that Western media does in
in the context of discussing Russia is
they create this aura of invincibility
around the Russian president they go you
know this guy's calling all the shots
he's pulling all the strings you know
this guy's in charge of the world and
that's very useful for the Russian
government broadly because they can then
take that and replay that on their
domestic media and they go look how
strong we are you know the Americans are
afraid of us the Chinese are afraid of
his everybody's afraid of us the French
were afraid of us we are strong right
there's no question that Russia is going
to be interfering in elections
there's no question that America is
gonna be interfering in Russian
elections right and nobody nobody likes
to talk about this and again I need to
substantiate that now that I've said
that I've got an old note that I've
signed a billion times the New York
Times published a story in the wake of
you know this contestant 2016 election
where they looked into the history of
electoral interference in Russia and the
Soviet Union and they found in roughly
50 years 36 different cases of election
interference by Russia or the Soviets
right this is not a new thing this is
something that always happens because
that's what intelligence services do
that's what they think they're being
paid for which is a sad thing but it's a
it's a reality because we aren't wise
enough to separate covert action from
intelligence gathering but in that same
study that they found 36 different cases
by the Russians in the Soviets they
found 81 different cases by the US and
this was published by a Scott chain in
the New York Times and both the
Washington Post as well but this is this
is the thing like there is a way to
criticize the Russian government's
policies without criticizing the Russian
people who are ordinary people who just
want to have a happy life they just want
to do better they want the same things
that you do right and every time people
go all Russia Russia Russia every time
people go Russia bad every time they go
Russia's doing this they go Russia's
doing that Russian people who have
nothing to do with the government feel
implicated by that like do you feel like
you're in charge of Donald Trump like do
you want to be have Donald Trump's
legacy around your neck and then people
go oh well you know you could overthrow
Donald Trump you know you could
overthrow Putin can you really like is
that how it works so yeah I mean look I
have no affiliation I have no love for
the Russian government it's not my
choice to be here and I've made it very
clear I would be happy to return home is
there any concern that they would deny
you visa I mean how how are you staying
there it's it's a good question so I
have a permanent residence people think
I'm on our side
no longer it's like a green card now
it's got to be renewed every three years
so yeah sure it's possible they could
kick me out and this was what the story
I was telling you about before in
Russian media was they were saying you
know the Russian government should take
some action against me or shouldn't be
welcome here or I should go home because
why is he criticizing the Russian
government right when they're the people
is that like the Russian version of Fox
News I don't know enough about Russian
media to tell you I think it's supposed
to be more like a Reuters or Associated
Press but the hell if I know but the the
the thing is this what's the alternative
right yes the Russian government could
screw me but they could screw me even if
I didn't say anything and so should I
shut up and be quiet in the face of
things that I think are in Justices
because it makes me safer well a lot of
pragmatic people will say yeah they say
you've done enough they saying you've
done your part you know they say
whatever be safe live long be happy but
I didn't come forward to be safe if I
wanted to be safe I'd still be sitting
in Hawaii making a hell of a lot of
money to spy on all of you right and
nobody ever would have known about this
the system would have gotten worse but
the system the world the future gets
worse every day that we don't do
something about every day that we stay
silent about all the injustice as we see
the world gets worse things get worse
and yeah it's risky yeah it's
uncomfortable but that's why we do it
because if we don't no one else will all
those years I was sitting hoping for
someone else to come forward and no one
did right that's because I was waiting
for a hero but there are no heroes right
there's only heroic decisions you are
never further than one decision away
from making a difference doesn't matter
where there's a big difference doesn't
matter if it was a small difference
because you don't have to save the world
by yourself in fact you can't all you
have to do is lay down one brick right
all you have to do is make things a
little bit better in a small way so
other people can lay their brick on top
of that or beside and together step by
step day by day year by year we build
the foundation of something better but
yeah it's not gonna be safe but it
doesn't matter because individually it's
it's not you know me whoever you are
that's the Ironman well I don't care if
you're the biggest doomsday prepper with
cans full of beans if the world ends
it's going to affect you we make things
better we become safe together right
collectively that is our strength that
is the power of civilization that is the
power that shapes the future because
even if you make life great for you
you're gonna die someday you're gonna be
forgotten someday your cans of beans are
gonna rot someday you can make things
safe or you can be more careful right
you can be more clever and there's
nothing wrong with that but at the end
of the day you have to recognize if
you're trying to eliminate all risks
from your life what you're actually
doing is eliminating all possibility
from your life you you're trying to
collapse the universe of outcomes such
that what you've lost is freedom you've
lost the ability to act because you were
afraid
that's a beautiful into this mess that's
a beautiful way to put it are you aware
at all of the current state of
surveillance and what if anything has
changed since your revelations yeah I
mean the big thing that's changed since
I was in 2013 is now it's mobile first
everything mobile was still a big deal
right and the intelligence community was
very much grappling to get its hands
around it and to deal with it but now
people are much less likely to use
laptop then use a desktop than then use
you know God any kind of wired phone
then they are to use a smart phone and
both Apple and Android devices
unfortunately
are not especially good in protecting
your privacy think right now you got a
smartphone right you might be listening
to this on a train somewhere and in
traffic right now or you Joe right now
you got a phone somewhere in the room
right the phone is turned off or at
least the screen is turned off it's
sitting there it's powered on and if
somebody sends you a message the screen
blinks to life how does that happen but
how is it that if someone from any
corner of the earth dials a number your
phone rings and nobody else's rings how
is it you can dial anybody else's number
and only their phone rings right every
smartphone every phone at all is
constantly connected to the nearest
cellular tower every phone even when the
screen is off you think it's doing
nothing you can't see it because radio
frequency emissions are invisible it's
screaming in the air saying Here I am
Here I am
here is my IMEI I think it's an
individual manufacturers Equipment
Identity and IMEI individual
manufacturers subscriber identity I
could be wrong on the break out there
but the the acronyms are the IMEI and
the IMSI and you can search for these
things there are two globally unique
identifiers that only exist anywhere in
the world in one place right this makes
your phone different than all my other
phones the IMEI is burned into the hand
side of your phone no matter what SIM
card you changed to it's always gonna be
the same and it's always gonna be
telling the phone network it's this
physical handset the IME si
is in your SIM card right and this is
what holds your phone number right it's
the basically the key the right to use
that phone number and so your phone is
sitting there doing nothing you think
but it's constantly shouting and saying
I'm here who is closest to me that's a
cell phone tower and every cell phone
tower with its big ears is listening for
these little cries for help and going
alright
I see Joe Rogan's phone right I see
Jaime's phone I see all these phones
they're here right now
and it compares notes with the other
Network towers and your smartphone
compares notes with them to go who do I
hear the loudest and who you hear the
loudest is a proxy for proximity for
closeness distance right they go whoever
I hear more loudly than anybody else
that's close to me so you're gonna be
bound to this cell phone tower and that
cell phone tower is gonna make a note a
permanent record saying this phone this
phone handset with this phone number at
this time was connected to me right and
based on your phone handset and your
phone number they can get your identity
right because you pay for this stuff
with your credit card and everything
like that and even if you don't right
it's still active at your house
overnight it's still active you know on
your nightstand when you're sleeping
it's still whatever the movements of
your phone are the movements of you as a
person and those are often quite ly
uniquely identifying it goes to your
home it goes to your workplace other
people don't have it sorry
and anyway it's constantly shouting this
out and then it compares notes with the
other parts and network and when
somebody is trying to get to a phone it
compares notes of the network compares
notes to go where is this phone with
this phone number in the world right now
and to that cell phone tower that is
closest to that phone it sends out a
signal saying we have a call for you
make your phones start ringing so your
owner can answer it and then it connects
it across this whole path but what this
means is that whenever you're carrying a
phone ever the phone is turned on
there's a record of your presence at
that place that is being made and
created by companies it does not need to
be kept forever and as fact there's no
good argument for it to be kept forever
but these companies see that is valuable
information Ryan this is the whole big
data problem that we're running into and
all this information that used to be
ephemeral right where were you when you
were 8 years old you know
we're worried where'd you go after you
had a bad breakup you know who'd you
spend the night with who'd you call
after all this information used to be
ephemeral meaning it disappeared right
like like the morning dew it would be
gone no one would remember it but now
these things are stored now these things
are saved it doesn't matter whether
you're doing anything wrong it doesn't
matter whether you're the most ordinary
person on earth because that's how bulk
collection which is the government's
euphemism for mass surveillance works
they simply collected all in advance in
hopes that one day it will become useful
and that was just talking about how you
connected phone network that's not
talking about all those apps on your
phone that are contacting the network
even more frequently right how do you
get a text message notification how do
you get an email notification how is it
the Facebook knows where you're at you
know all of these things these analytics
they are trying to keep track through
location services on your phone to GPS
through even just what wireless access
points you're connected to because
there's a global constantly updated map
there's actually many of them of
wireless access points in the world
because just like we talked about every
phone has a unique identifier that's
globally unique every wireless access
point in the world right you cable modem
at home
whether it's in your laptop every device
that has a radio modem has a globally
unique identifier in it and this is
standard term you can look it up and
these things can be mapped when they're
broadcasting in the air because again
like your phone says to the cell phone
tower I have this identifier the cell
phone tower responds and says I have
this identifier and anybody who's
listening they can write these things
down and all there's Google Street View
cars that go back and forth right
they're keeping notes on whose Wi-Fi is
active on this block right and then they
build a new giant map so even if you
have GPS turned off right as long as you
connect to the Wi-Fi those apps can go
well I I'm connected to Joe's Wi-Fi but
I can also see his neighbor's Wi-Fi here
and the other one in this apartment over
here and the other one in the apartment
here
and you should only be able to hear
those four globally unique Wi-Fi access
points from these points in physical
space right the intersection in between
the spreads the domes of all those
wireless access points it's a proxy for
location and it just goes on and on and
on we could talk about this for four
more hours we don't have that kind of
time
can I ask you this is there a way to
mitigate any of this personally I mean
is shutting your phone off doesn't even
work right well so it does in a way it's
just no uhm the thing was shutting your
phone off that is a risk is how do you
know any phones actually turned off it
used to be when I was in Geneva for
example working for the CIA we would all
carry like drug dealer phones you know
the old smart phones there sorry old
dumb phones they're not smart phones and
the reason why was just because they had
removable battery bags where you could
take the battery out right and the one
beautiful thing about technology is if
there's no electricity in it right if
there's no go juice available to it if
there's no battery connected to it it's
not sending anything because you have to
get power from somewhere you have to
have power in order to do work but now
your phones are all sealed right you
can't take the batteries out so there
are potential ways that you can hack a
phone where it appears to be off but
it's not actually off it's just
pretending to be off whereas in fact
it's still listening in and doing all
this stuff but for the average person
that doesn't apply right and I got to
tell you guys they've been chasing me
all over the place I don't worry about
that stuff right and it's because if
they are applying that level of effort
to me they'll probably get the same
information through other routes I am as
careful as I can and I use things like
Faraday cages I turn devices off but if
they're actually manipulating the way
devices display it's just too great a
level of effort even for someone like me
to keep that up on a constant basis also
if they get me I only trust phones so
much so there's only so much they can
derive from
compromise and this is how operational
security works you think about what are
the realistic threats that you're facing
that you're trying to mitigate and with
the mitigation that you're trying to do
is what would be the loss what would be
the damage done to you if this stuff was
exploited much more realistic than
worrying about these things that I call
voodoo hacks right which are like
next-level stuff and actually just a
shout out for those of your readers who
are interested in this stuff fun I wrote
a paper on this specific problem how do
you know when a phone is actually off
how do you know when it's actually not
spying on you with a brilliant brilliant
guy named Andrew bunny Huang he's an MIT
PhD and I think electrical engineering
called the introspection engine that was
published in the Journal of hope and
engineering you can find it online and
it'll go as deep down in the weeds I
promise you it as you want we take an
iPhone 6 this was back when it was
fairly new and we modified it so we
could actually not trust the device to
report its own state but physically
monitor its state to see if were spying
on you but for average people right this
academic that's not your primary thread
your primary threats are these bulk
collection programs your primary threat
is the fact that your phone is
constantly squawking to these cell phone
towers it's doing all of these things
because we leave our phones a mistake
that is constantly on your constantly
connected right airplane mode doesn't
even turn off Wi-Fi really anymore it
just turns off the cellular modem but
the whole idea is we need to identify
the problem and the central problem with
smart phone use today is you have no
idea what the hell it's doing at any
given time like the phone has the screen
off you don't know what it's connected
to you don't know how frequently it's
doing it Apple and iOS unfortunately
makes it impossible to see what kind of
network connections are constantly made
on the device and to inter mediate them
going I don't want Facebook to be able
to talk right now you know I don't want
Google to be able to talk right now
I just want my secure messenger app to
be
the talk I just want my weather app to
be able to talk but I just checked my
weather and now I'm done with it so I
don't want that to be able to talk
anymore and we need to be able to make
these intelligent decisions on not just
an app by app basis but a connection by
connection basis right you want let's
say you use Facebook because you know
for whatever judgment we have a lot of
people might do it you want it to be
able to connect to Facebook's content
servers you want to be able to message a
friend you want to be able to download a
photograph or whatever but you don't
want it to be able to talk to an ad
server you don't want it to talk to an
analytics server that it's monitoring
your behavior right you don't want to
talk to all these third-party things
because Facebook crams their garbage and
almost every app that you download and
you don't even know what's happening
because you can't see it right and this
is the problem with the data collection
used today is there is an industry that
is built on keeping this invisible and
what we need to do is we need to make
the activities of our devices whether
it's a phone whether it's computer or
whatever more visible and understandable
to the average person and then give them
control over it so like if you could see
your phone right now and at the very
center of is a little green icon that's
your you know handset or it's a picture
your face whatever and then you see all
these little spokes coming off of it
that's every app that your phone is
talking to right now or every app that
is active on your phone right now and
all the hosts that it's connecting to
and you can see right now what's every
three seconds your phone is checking
into Facebook and you could just poke
that app and then BOOM it's not talking
to Facebook anymore Facebook's not
allowed Facebook speaking privileges
have been revoked right you would do
that we would all do that if there was a
button on your phone that said do what I
want but not spy on me you would press
that button right that button is not a
does not exist right now and both Google
and Apple
unfortunately Apple's a lot better at
this than Google but neither of them
allow that button to exist in fact they
actively interfere with it because they
say it's a security risk and from a
particular perspective
they actually aren't wrong there but
it's not enough to go you know we have
to lock that capability off from people
because we don't trust they would make
the right decisions we think it's too
complicated for people to do this we
think there's too many connections being
made well that is actually a confession
of the problem right there if you think
people can't understand it if you think
there are too many communications
happening if you think there's too much
complexity in there it needs to be
simplified
just like the president can't control
everything like that if you have to be
the president of the phone and the phone
is as complex as the United States
government we have a problem guys this
should be a much more simple process it
should be obvious and the fact that it's
not and the fact that we read story
after story
year after year saying all your date has
been breached here this companies spying
on you here this companies manipulating
your purchases or your search results or
they're hiding these things from your
timeline or they're influencing your you
are manipulating it in all of these
different ways that happens as a result
of a single problem and that problem is
in any quality of available information
they can see everything about you they
can see everything about what your
device is doing and they can do whatever
they want with your device you on the
other hand owns the device well rather
you paid for the device but increasingly
these corporations on it increasingly
these government's own it and
increasingly we are living in a world
where we do all the work right we pay
all the taxes we pay all the costs but
we own less and less and nobody
understands this better than the
youngest generation well it seems like
our data became a commodity before we
understood what it was it became this
thing that's insanely valuable to Google
and Facebook and all these social media
platforms before we understood what we
were giving up they were making billions
of dollars and then once that money is
being earned and once everyone's
accustomed to this situation
it's very difficult to pull the reins
back it's very difficult to turn that
horse around
precisely because the money then becomes
pot right right the information that
becomes influence
that also seems to be the same sort of
situation that would happen with these
mass surveillance dates once they have
the access it's going to be incredibly
difficult for them to relinquish that
right yeah no you're you're exactly
correct and this is the the subject of
the book I mean this is this is the
permanent record and this is where it
came from this is how it came to exist
the story of our lifetimes is how
intentionally by design a number of
institutions both governmental and
corporate realized it was in their
mutual interest to conceal their data
collection activities to increase the
breadth and depth of their sensor
networks that were sort of spread out
through society remember back in the day
intelligence collection in the United
States even at Sigyn used to mean
sending an FBI agent right to put
alligator clips on an embassy building
or sending in somebody disguised as a
workman and they put a bug in a building
or they built a satellite listening site
right we called these foreign said were
foreign satellite collection we're on
the desert somewhere they built a big
parabolic collector and it's just
listening to satellite emissions right
but these satellite emissions these
satellite links were owned by militaries
they were exclusive to governments right
it wasn't affecting everybody broadly
all surveillance was targeted because it
had to be what changed with technology
is that surveillance could now become
indiscriminate it could become dragnet
it could become bulk collection which
should become one of the dirtiest
phrases in the language if we have any
kind of decency but we were
intentionally this was intentionally
concealed from us right the government
did it they used classification
companies did it they intentionally
didn't talk about it they denied these
things were going they said you agreed
to this and you didn't greeted nothing
like this I'm sorry right they go we put
that Terms of Service page up and you
that you clicked a button that said I
agree because you were trying to open an
account so you could talk to your
friends you were trying to get driving
directions you were trying to get an
email account you weren't trying to
agree to some 600 page legal form that
even if you read you wouldn't understand
and it doesn't matter even if you did
understand because one of the very first
paragraphs and I said this agreement can
be changed at any time unilaterally
without your consent by the company
right they have built a legal paradigm
that presumes records collected about us
do not belong to us this is sort of one
of the core principles on which mass
surveillance from the government's
perspective in the United States is
legal and you have to understand that
all the stuff we talked about today
government says everything they do is
legal right and they go so it's fine our
perspectives the public should be well
that's actually the problem because this
isn't okay
the scandal isn't how they're breaking
the law the scandal is that they don't
have to break the law and the way they
say they're not breaking the law is
something called the third party
doctrine the third party doctrine is a
legal principle and derived from a case
and I believe the 1970s called Smith
versus Maryland and Smith was this
knucklehead who was harassing this lady
making phone calls to her house and when
she would pick up you just I don't know
is that their heavy breathing whatever
like a classic creeper and you know it
was terrifying this poor lady so she
calls the cops and says one day I got
one of these phone calls and then I see
this car
creeping past my house on the street and
she got a license-plate number so she
goes the cops and she goes is this the
guy and the cops again they're trying to
do a good thing here they look up his
license-plate number and they find out
where this guy is and then they go what
phone number is registered to that house
and they go to the phone company and
they say can you give us this record the
phone company says yeah sure and it's
the guy the cops got their man
right huh so they go arrest this guy and
then in court his lawyer brings all this
stuff up and they go um you did this
without a warrant that was sorry that
was that was the the problem was they
went to the phone company they got the
records without a warrant they just
asked for it or they subpoenaed it right
some lower standard of legal review and
the company gave it to him and got the
guy they march amok in jail and they
could have gotten a warrant right but it
was just expedience they just didn't
want to take the time with small-town
cops you can understand how it happens
they know the guy's a creep or they just
want to get him off to jail and so they
made him I said but the government
doesn't want to let go they fight on
this and they go it wasn't actually they
weren't his records and so because they
didn't belong to him he didn't have a
Fourth Amendment right to demand a
warrant be issued for them they were the
company's records and the company
provided them voluntarily and hence no
warrant was required because you can
give whatever you want without a warrant
as long as it's yours now here's the
problem the government extrapolated a
principle in a single case of a single
known suspected criminal who had they
had real good reasons suspect suspect
was their guy and used that to go to a
company and get records from them and
establish the precedent these records
don't belong to the guy they belong to
the company and then they said well if
one person doesn't have a Fourth
Amendment interest in records held by a
company no one does and so the company
then has absolute proprietary ownership
of all of these records about all of our
lives and remember this is back in the
1970s you know the internet hardly
exists in these kind of contexts
smartphones you know don't exist modern
society modern communications don't
exist this is the very beginning of the
technological era and flash-forward now
40 years
and they are still relying on this
precedent about this one
you know pervy creeper to go nobody has
a privacy right for anything that's held
by a company and so long as they do that
companies are going to be
extraordinarily powerful and they're
going to be extraordinarily abusive and
this is something that people don't get
they go oh well it's data collection
right they're exploiting data this is
data about human lives mistake about
people these records are about you it's
not data that's being exploited it's
people that are being exploited it's not
data that's being manipulated it's you
that's being manipulated and this this
is this is something that I think a lot
of people are beginning to understand
the problem is the companies in the
government's are still pretending they
don't understand were disagreeing with
this and this is reminds me of something
that one of my old friends John Perry
Barlow who served with me at the freedom
of the press foundation I'm the
president of the board he used to say to
me which is you can't awaken someone
who's pretending to be asleep he said
it's an old Native American saying
that's a great expression it's a good
way that I think that's a good way to
end this thank you very much for doing
this I really appreciate it please tell
everybody the title of your book and
it's it's available right now
sure yes it is it's on shelves
everywhere at least until the government
finds some other way to ban it it is
called a permanent record and I hope
you'll read it I will read it and I
think what you've done is incredibly
brave and I think you're a very
important part of history I think when
all is said and done what you did and
what you exposed is gonna change the way
we view mass surveillance change the way
we view government oversight and it
changed the way we view the distribution
of information I really think it's very
very important and it was an honor to
talk to you man thank you
it was my pleasure thank you so much for
having take care yourself man stay safe
no no no no don't stay safe stay safe
open space days free open to
possibilities take care thank you
[Music]